हेलो एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो सबसे पहले मुझे ये बताइए सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है लाउड एंड
क्लियर ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू एवरीवन थैंक
यू तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं देर ओनली अभी
स्टूडेंट्स है आज तो शायद ज्यादा स्टूडेंट
आने चाहिए क्योंकि नया टॉपिक है और शायद
सब लोगों के लिए नई चीजें होंगी ओके
क्योंकि विंडोज के बारे में जो चीज मैं
आपको सिखाने वाला हूं जो चीज मैं आपको
बताने वाला
हूं शायद आपको कोई भी एथिकल हैकिंग में
नहीं बताता होगा शायद मैं उम्मीद कर सकता
हूं कोई बताता होगा तो बहुत अच्छा अच्छी
बात है ही एंड शी इज वेरी गुड ट्रेनर ओके
तो
जो अभी कुछ किसी का कोई सवाल था कि सर
लास्ट क्लास में हमारी लिनक्स प्लेज
एस्केलेशन हुई है ओनली डे वन बट उसके बाद
आपने विंडोज को स्टार्ट कर दिया तो बात
ऐसी है मेरी जो काली नेक्स मशीन है उसमें
थोड़े से ग्लिच हो गए हैं थोड़ी सी
टेक्निकल प्रॉब्लम हो गई है तो जिसकी वजह
से मैंने उसको अन इंस्टॉल करना पड़ा और
थोड़ा सा उसको टाइम लगेगा इंस्टॉल करके और
चीजों को थोड़ा सा रिजॉल्व करने में तो
उसकी वजह से मैं नहीं चाहता था कि हमारी
क्लास डिले हो और काफी टाइम से हम
[संगीत]
तो यह सारी चीजें मैं सिखाऊंगा क् क्लियर
ट्रैक्स तो यह आप लोगों को चिंता करने की
बिल्कुल भी जरूरत नहीं है
क्योंकि थोड़ा सा प्रॉब्लम की वजह से
मैंने सोचा कि थोड़ा सा स्विच कर लेते हैं
कुछ फंडामेंटल्स या विंडोज पे स्विच कर
लेते हैं विंडो के बारे में जानते हैं
अपनी क्लास को कंटिन्यू करते हैं सिलेबस
को लेट नहीं करेंगे देन उसके बाद हम
कंटिन्यू फिर से कम बैक टू आवर लिनक्स प्
एस्केलेशन की जो लैब्स हमारी बची हुई थी
जो हमारा टॉपिक पेंडिंग है
शायद आप लोगों को इससे रिलेटेड कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं होनी चाहिए किसी को कोई
प्रॉब्लम है मे स्विच करने से क्योंकि य
मेरी साइड से प्रॉब्लम्स है तो अदर वाइज
मेरे को आठ या 10 दिन तक और क्लास नहीं
लेनी पड़ती तो मे बी ट वास द प्रॉब्लमैटिक
डीसी जेएसपी में तो नितेश सर पढ़ाते
हैं ओके वेरी गुड तो अच्छी बात है आप लोग
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है तो स वेरी गुड तो
अभी भी स्टूडेंट 50 स्टूडेंट्स भी नहीं आए
क्योंकि आज जो इंफॉर्मेशन आज से आप जो जो
इंफॉर्मेशन लेने वाले विंडो के बारे में
लिटरली आप लोगों को लगेगा कि सर यह
इंफॉर्मेशन एज ए एथिकल हैकर्स या एज ए
पेंटेस्टर्स हमारे लिए क्यों जरूरी है बट
जैसे ही आप प्रोफेशनल एथिकल हैकर बनोगे
जैसे-जैसे आप एडवांस लेवल पर जाओगे तब
आपको यह छोटी-छोटी चीजें हैं जो आपको को
हमेशा याद आएंगे कि ओके हमने एक फ्री
क्लास में कभी सचिन सर ने पढ़ाया था तो यह
टॉपिक ये है और मैं यहां पर यह चीज अभी
ट्राई कर रहा हूं तो शायद उस टाइम पर आपको
मेरी याद आएगी और अगर आप लोग मिस कर दोगे
तो शायद फिर आपको मेरी याद नहीं आएगी
ओके तो हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं
नेक्स्ट न मिनट में
यस बुक द आर्ट ऑफ एक्सप्लोइटेशन इज वेरी
गुड काफी अच्छी बुक है अगर आपको सी
लैंग्वेज में एक्सप्लोइटेशन परफॉर्म करना
है तो एक्सप्लोइट बनाने सीखने हैं तो वेरी
गुड बहुत अच्छी बुक है यह काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग बुक है शायद एवरी एथिकल
हैकर्स को ए पेंटेस्टर सबको पढ़नी चाहिए
आई रिकमेंड
तो क्लास को स्टार्ट करें
फिर हम टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे
फिर तो ज्यादा स्टूडेंट तो आएंगे नहीं
मुझे पता है स्टूडेंट्स को कोई इंटरेस्ट
होता नहीं
है आप लोग एक चलो एक मिनट का टाइम लेता
हूं मैं और शायद अभी आप लोगों के साथ पलब
पलब अभी धर है ओके तो पलब इसका एक
एग्जांपल है कि लास्ट टाइम क्लास में हमसे
पूछ रहे थे कि सर मेरे को एक डोमेन मिला
है उस परे मुझे पेन टेस्ट करनी है तो मुझे
थोड़ा सा गाइड कीजिए और वह क्लाउड फ्रंट
की वजह से जो एक्चुअल जो आईपी एड्रेस था
वह ले नहीं पा रहे थे अभी मैंने समझाया और
सबको मैं य समझाता हूं जब तक आपको को
फंडामेंटल्स क्लियर नहीं है जब तक आपके
पास एक अप्रोच नहीं है तो दूसरों की हेल्प
लेकर कब तक करोगे
यार आपको अगर कांसेप्ट समझ में आते
प्रैक्टिकल में फेल हो रहे हो तो सोचिए कि
कांसेप्ट यह था प्रैक्टिकली मैं य अप्लाई
कर रहा हूं उसके बाद मैं फिर भी फेल क्यों
हो रहा हूं किस चीज की कमी है यहां पर किस
चीज की मुझे अब इंप्रूव करना पड़ेगा किस
चीज में क्या मेरा प्रैक्टिकल कांसेप्ट और
जो मेरा एक्चुअल जो जो मैंने सीखा है वो
रिलेट कर भी पा रहे या नहीं कर पा रहे या
दोनों रिलेट कर पा रहे तो क्या उसके लिए
मैं जिस टूल को यूज कर रहा हूं क्या वो एक
परफेक्ट टूल है या नहीं है या मेरी जो
अप्रोच परफेक्ट है या नहीं है यह सारी की
सारी चीजें आपकी बहुत मायने रखती
है और यह चीज में आपको अभी समझ में नहीं
आए क्योंकि आप लोगों को क्या ना हर चीज
जल्दी करनी है पेशेंस और अगर यू आर एथिकल
हैकर और यू आर पेन
टेस्टर तो आपको
बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है आप एक मिनट में लाइक
ए मूवी कोई भी थिएटर में मूवी चलती है कोई
भी आपने जितनी भी मूवी देखी उनकी तरह आप
एक मिनट में वह परफॉर्म नहीं कर
सकते वह कहते ना कि आपके सालों की मेहनत
वह सिर्फ कुछ
सेकंड जो मूवी में दिखाई गई होती
है ओके तो मैं आपको वही बोलूंगा कि
आप अपने आप को जो बोलते हैं कि पेशेंस
रखिए और पेशेंस के साथ साथ अपने कांसेप्ट
उनको कंपेयर कीजिए और सर्च कीजिए
google3 के बारे में कुछ जिक्र किया नहीं
है और जहां पर आप वेब पन टेस्टिंग के बारे
में बात कर रहे हो तो वो नित्या सर बग
बाउटी में करवा रहे हैं मैंने तो ऐसा कुछ
करवाया नहीं है मेरे कांसेप्ट क्या है कि
आपके इंटरनेट क्योंकि आप एक आईपी रेंज में
हो या उस नेटवर्क से आप कनेक्टेड हो जब आप
उस नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड हो वाया लन वाया
वाईफाई मतलब उन्हीं के नेटवर्क में हो तब
आप किस तरीके से पेन टेस्टिंग कर सकते हो
मैं वो वो कांसेप्ट आपको बता रहा हूं
लेकिन आप मेरे कांसेप्ट डायरेक्टली अप्लाई
कर रहे हो वेबसाइट पर तो आप सोचिए ना कि
आपका कांसेप्ट मैच ही नहीं हो रहा मैं जो
करवा रहा और जो आप अप्लाई कर रहे हो बोथ
आर
डिफरेंट क्योंकि वेबसाइट पेन टेस्टिंग एक
जरिया है इस कांसेप्ट को एक साथ एडजस्ट
करने का बट मैं आपको हर बार एग्जांपल क्या
देता हूं कि आई एम द पार्ट ऑफ ट इंटरनल
नेटवर्क देन मैं एंड में वो मेरे पास आईपी
रेंज है मेरे पास आईपी एड्रेस है देन उसके
ऊपर में सारे एमेशन स्कैनिंग सब कुछ
परफॉर्म कर रहा हूं यह मेरी अप्रोच रहती
है
हमेशा ओके तो
अभी एक काम करते हैं क्लास स्टार्ट करते
हैं ऑलरेडी 10 मिनट हमने वेट कर दिया नहीं
तो स्टूडेंट्स अभी क्या करेंगे ना चले
जाएंगे छोड़ के
तो इट विल टेक टाइम ऑर्बिट एक्स वाई जड
क्योंकि स्टेप बाय स्टेप हम जा रहे हैं तो
आज का हमारे कांसेप्ट है व काफी
इंपोर्टेंट कांसेप्ट है अभी आप लोगों सेरी
रिक्वेस्ट है अगले एक घंटे के लिए प्लीज
आपके जो भी डाउट्स है रिलेटेड टू द
कांसेप्ट या रिलेटेड टू द टॉपिक अपने पास
रखिए क्योंकि
अभी मैं सिर्फ टोटली कांसेप्ट डिलीवर
करूंगा ओके कांसेप्ट डिलीवर करने के बाद
फिर मैं आपसे पूछूंगा कि जो कुछ मैंने आज
विंडो से रिलेटेड करवाया आपको क्या आपको
समझ में आया नहीं आया या आपके जो डाउट्स
हैं वो मैं आपके एंड ऑफ दद सेशन मैं आपके
ले लूंगा और उसका आंसर मैं आपको करूंगा ही
करूंगा बट अभी क्या है कि मैं आपके चैट
देखूंगा नहीं ज्यादातर अगर मैं पूछता हूं
आपको किसी सवाल का आंसर पूछता हूं तो तभी
मैं आपके चैट देखूंगा अभी मैं आपके चैट
नहीं देखने वाला तो आई रिक्वेस्ट प्लीज
टॉपिक पर फोकस कीजिए और शायद आज का जो
टॉपिक मैं करवाने वाला हूं वह काफी
इंपोर्टेंट
एज आप आईटी गाय या किसी भी नजरिए से लो आप
चाहे सिक्योरिटी पेंटेस्ट हो यह काफी
इंपोर्टेंट है हर किसी के लिए समझना कि जो
टॉपिक हमारा बूट प्रोसेस ऑफ विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कि विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की जो आपका विंडोज है वो बूट कैसे
करता है स्टेप बाय स्टेप कि हमें तो जस्ट
लगता है कि कुछ चंद सेकंड में आपके सामने
एक लॉगइन स्क्रीन आ जाती है बट उसके पीछे
क्या-क्या चीजें हो रही होती हैं उसके
पीछे कौन-कौन सी प्रोसेस रिस्पांसिबल होती
है और क्या-क्या काम हो रहा होता है उसके
बारे में हम ओनली आज उसी के बारे में
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं तो प्लीज बेयर विद
मी मेरे साथ जुड़े रहिए और कांसेप्ट को
सीखने की कोशिश कीजिए ओके तो अभी हम एक
काम करते हैं सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं और
जो हमारा टॉपिक है कुछ अगले कुछ क्लासेस
के लिए हमारा टॉपिक है फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ
विंडोज विंडोज के बारे में हम बहुत सारी
चीजें सीखने वाले हैं उसके फंडामेंटल्स के
बारे में जैसे कि उस डीप डाइव मतलब हम
अंदर जा जा के सीखेंगे कि विंडोज की
बूटिंग प्रोसेस कैसे काम करती है सर्विसेस
क्या होती हैं रजिस्ट्री क्या क्या होती
है डील्स क्या होती हैं कैसे एप्लीकेशन
उसके ऊपर काम करती हैं उसके बाद विंडोज की
जो कमांड प्र में कमांड कौन-कौन सी आपके
लिए एज ए पेंटेस्ट यूजफुल कमांड्स है यह स
चीज हम सीखने वाले हैं देन उसके बाद हम
विंडोज की पेन टेस्टिंग करना सीखेंगे ओके
तो यह हमारी अप्रोच रहेगी सबसे पहले मैं
आपको उस लेवल का फंडामेंटल बताऊंगा कि जब
आप कभी एडवांस कोर्स पढ़ोगे विंडोज की जब
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करोगे किसी भी एडवांस
कोर्स में तब यह टॉपिक आपके बहुत ज्यादा
हेल्पफुल रहेंगे ओके तो स्टार्ट करें
अभी स्टार्ट करें अभी एवरीवन
जल्दी से चैट में बताइए अभी मैं चैट देख
रहा हूं अगले मिनट के लिए
ओके चलो तो आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक है
बूटिंग प्रोसेस ऑफ विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
उसके बारे में हम पढ़ने वाले हैं कि
विंडोज बूट कैसे करता है
तो हम बात करेंगे इन डेप्थ स्टेप बाय
स्टेप एक्सप्लेनेशन किसकी विंडोज बूट
प्रोसेस की द विंडोज बूट प्रोसेस कंसिस्ट
ऑफ मल्टीपल स्टेप्स ईच इवॉल्विंग डिफरेंट
कंपोनेंट्स
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर इनिला इजिंग द सिस्टम एंड
लोडिंग द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बेसिकली क्या
होता है कि जब भी आपकी विंडोज बूट करती है
जब भी आपके मशीन में विंडोज का ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम लोड होता है तो वह मल्टीपल स्टेप्स
फॉलो करता है ओके मल्टीपल स्टेप्स फॉलो
करता है अभी आपके पावर ऑन बटन से लेके जब
आपने आपके सीपीयू के अंदर या आपके लैपटॉप
के अंदर जब आपने उसका पावर न बटन प्रेस
किया तब से लेकर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लोड होने
तक देयर आर मल्टीपल स्टेप्स आर
अवेलेबल इवॉल्व उसके लिए दे लॉट ऑफ
स्टेप्स आर इवॉल्वड उसके लिए क्या होता है
उन स्टेप्स में दे डिफरेंट डिफरेंट टाइप्स
ऑफ कंपोनेंट दैट आर रिस्पांसिबल फॉर इनिला
इजिंग द सिस्टम और लोडिंग द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम मतलब सिस्टम को इनिश इज करने के
लिए मतलब जब आपने पावर ऑन किया आपके
सिस्टम को और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लोड होने तक
जो आपने लॉगिन स्क्रीन आती है उसके बीच
में अलग-अलग कंपोनेंट्स
बहुत सारे कंपोनेंट्स हैं जो आपके
सिस्टम्स में काम करते हैं हर एक कंपोनेंट
की एक अपनी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है कौन सा
कंपोनेंट क्या काम करता है उसके बारे में
हम सीखने वाले हैं काफी डीप में जाके तो
लेट्स सी डिटेल स्टेप बाय स्टेप ब्रेक
डाउन ऑफ द एंटा बड प्रोसेस इसके बारे में
हम सीखते हैं तो बिल्कुल
ध्यान से समझना एक एक चीज को क्योंकि आपके
बहुत काम आने वाली है तो सबसे पहले हम बात
करते हैं जैसे ही आप सिस्टम को पावर ऑन
करते हो क्या होता
है वन ए कंप्यूटर इज पावर ऑन एक मिनट
ओके नाउ व्हेन ए कंप्यूटर इज पावर ऑन द
एंटायस स्टार्ट विद इनिला इजिंग हार्डवेयर
कंपोनेंट्स इंश्योर स्टेबल पावर
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन एंड प्रिपेयरिंग द सिस्टम
फॉर फर्मवेयर एग्जीक्यूशन बेसिकली क्या
होता है कि जैसे ही आप अपने जो पावर का
बटन है आपको देखने को मिल रहा हो यहां पर
सीपीयू के अंदर जैसे ही आप उसका जो पावर
का बटन है उसको प्रेस करते हो सीपीयू के
अंदर तो उसके अंदर एक सर्किट होता है और
जैसे आप प्रेस करते हो वह सर्किट क्या
करता है सिग्नल भेजता है आपके पीएसयू को
किसको आपके पीएसयू को पावर सप्लाई यूनिट
सबको पता है कि आपका चाहे लैपटॉप हो चाहे
आपका वो क्या बोल सकते हो आप सीपीयू हो जो
डेस्कटॉप हो उसके अंदर पीएससी होती है
पावर सप्लाई यूनिट उसके पास सिग्नल भेज
देता है ओके तो अभी जैसे ही आप उसको पावर
ऑन करते हो तो जो पीएसयू है उसकी एक
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है और पीएसयू क्या काम
करता है जो एससी सिग्नल क्योंकि जब भी आप
अपने पीसी को अपने लैपटॉप को वाया चार्जर
या व्हाट एवर एनी मीडियम आप क्या करते हो
प्लग करते हो अपने होम पावर सप्लाई में तो
वहां पर जो पावर सप्लाई आती है वो एसी आती
है तो उसको क्या करता है एसी पावर सप्लाई
को डीसी पावर सिग्नल में कन्वर्ट कर देता
है आपका पीएसयू उसकी जिम्मेदारी दूसरा
क्या करता है कि डिस्ट्री ट पावर टू द
मदरबोर्ड सीपीयू रम जीपीयू स्टोरेज एंड
पेरिफेरल जितने भी पेरीफेरल्स है आपके
किसके अंदर इसके अंदर पैनल के अंदर आपका
जो जिसको आप बोल सकते हो सीपीओ जो कैबिनेट
होता है उसके अंदर जितने भी पेरिफेरल
डिवाइसेज है या उसके अंदर जितने भी
स्टोरेज है जीपीयू है रम है या सीपीयू मदर
मोड सबको क्या करता है उस पावर सप्लाई को
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर देता है और साथ के साथ
इंश्योर करता है कि पावर इ स्टेबल बिफोर
अलांग द सिस्टम प्रोसीड कि बाकी सारे के
सारे जो कंपोनेंट है वो ऑन होने से पहले
यह पक्का इंश्योर करता है आपका पीएसयू कि
जो पावर उनको डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर है वो स्टेबल
है मतलब उसमें कोई भी फ्लक्ट एशन नहीं है
ओके अब ये कैसे इंश्योर करता है आपका
पीएसयू आल्सो परफॉर्म इट सेल्फ इट इट्स
सेल्फ टेस्ट पीएसवी भी क्या करता है आपका
जो ये पावर सप्लाई यूनिट होती है छोटा सा
बॉक्स जो आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा आपके
स्क्रीन के ऊपर क्या अग इसके अंदर भी क्या
होता है ये अपना सेल्फ टेस्ट परफॉर्म करता
है बिफोर सेंडिंग द पावर टू अदर कंपोनेंट
पीएसओ चेक करता है कि उसके पास जो वोल्टेज
आनी चाहिए कि मतलब आपका जो
अ सीपीयू है उसको जितनी रिक्वायरमेंट है
जितनी वोल्टेज की रिक्वायरमेंट है उसके
हिसाब से यहां पर एग्जांपल जैसे 3.3 वोल्ट
5 वोल्ट या 12 वोल्ट कि वो उतनी
रिक्वायर्ड अमाउंट में वोल्टेज उसके पास आ
रही है या नहीं आ रही ये चेक करता है
सेल्फ टेस्ट में इफ वोल्टेज आर करेक्ट अगर
उसको जो वोल्टेज मिल रही है अगर वो सही है
तो द पावर गुड एक पीजी सिग्नल होता है इज
सेंड टू द मदरबोर्ड चिपसेट ठीक है कि ये
पावर गुड का सिग्नल आपके मदर बोर्ड चिपसेट
को भेज देता है इफ द पीजी सिग्नल इज
एब्सेंट अगर पावर गुड सिग्नल आपके
मदरबोर्ड को नहीं मिलता इसका मतलब आपका जो
सिस्टम है बूट नहीं होगा इसलिए जब मैंने
बोला जैसे ही आप अपने सिस्टम का जो पावर
बटन ऑन करते हो तो जो एंटायस प्रोसेस है
वो स्टार्ट कर दे ती है आपके हार्डवेयर
कंपोनेंट को इनिश इज करना और साथ के साथ
यह भी इंश्योर करती है कि जो उसको पावर
मिल रही है जितने भी हार्डवेयर कंपोनेंट्स
हैं वो स्टेबल पावर मिल रही है एंड सिस्टम
को फर्मवेयर एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए रेडी करना
ये सारी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी होती है आपकी
लेकिन सबसे पहले जो सिग्नल जाता है आपके
पीएसयू के बास जाता है पीएसयू क्या करता
है ये सारी चीजें मेक श्योर करता है खुद
का सेल्फ टेस्ट करता है और ये 100% मेक
श्यर करता है कि जो पावर सप्लाई आई है वो
पावर सप्लाई स्टेबल है उसमें कोई भी
फ्लक्ट एश नहीं है उसके बाद य क्या करता
है एक सिग्नल होता है पावर गुड सिग्नल
किसके पास भेज देता है मदर बोर्ड के बाद
तो ये चीज सबको समझ में आई यहां तक यहां
तक सबको समझ में
आई ये चीज सबको समझ में यहां
तक आई डोंट की ओके तो अभी हम कंटिन्यू
करते हैं देन उसके बाद क्या होता है कि द
मदर बोर्ड रिसीव द पावर ऑन सिग्नल जो आपका
मदर मोड है जैसे कि पीएसयू है पीएसयू से
आपका जो मदर मोड आपको डायग्राम के के साथ
बिल्कुल मैक्सिमम चीजें आपको डायग्राम के
साथ देखने को मिलेगी जैसे ये आपको मैं
डायग्राम में शो हुआ है कि जो मदरबोर्ड्स
है उसके पास आपको पीजी सिग्नल मिलता है
पावर ऑन सिग्नल एंड बिगिंस द बूट सीक्वेंस
जैसे ही उसको पावर ऑन सिग्नल मिलता है तो
वो अपना बूट सीक्वेंस स्टार्ट कर देता है
वंस द पावर गुड सिग्नल इज रिसीवड द
वोल्टेज रेगुलेटर ऑन द मदरबोर्ड इंश्योर
ईच कंपोनेंट गेट रिक्वायर्ड वोल्टेज ओके
और जैसे ही उसको पावर गुड सिग्नल मिलता है
कि पावर अ ओके जो पीएसयू से पावर सप्लाई आ
रही है वो गुड पावर सप्लाई है मतलब उसमें
कोई
फ्लक्शनल बोर्ड में भी एक वोल्टेज
रेगुलेटर होता है जो यह मेक श्योर करता है
कि जितने भी कंपोनेंट्स लगे हैं जैसे
एसएसडी होगी जीपीयू होगा रम होगा या आपका
जो सीपीयू चिप लगी हुई है उनको भी फॉर
एग्जांपल यहां पर मैंने एग्जांपल में शो
हुआ है कि 1.1 वोल्ट 1.3 फॉर एग्जांपल
इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट है चिप की एसएसडी की
रिक्वायरमेंट 5 वोल्ट 12 वोल्ट है जीपीयू
रिक्वायरमेंट 12 वोल्ट है या रम की
रिक्वायरमेंट है डीडीआर 4 1 2 वोल्ट या ये
मैंने एग्जांपल के साथ मेंशन किया तो इनकी
रिक्वायरमेंट को फुलफिल करना फुलफिल करता
है आपका मदरबोर्ड कि इनको जितनी
रिक्वायरमेंट पावर सप्लाई की उतनी पावर
सप्लाई प्रोवाइड करता है वोल्टेज रेगुलेटर
जो आपका मदर बोर्ड में है तो पावर सिग्नल
पीएसयू से उसको अ पीजी सिग्नल मिला और
वोल्टेज रेगुलेटर फिरर मेक श्योर करता है
कि जितने भी जो कंपोनेंट्स आपके मदर बोर्ड
के अंदर जिस कंपोनेंट को जितनी पावर चाहिए
वो सारी पावर डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर है यह चीज
इंश्योर करता है नेक्स्ट उसके बाद हम बात
करते हैं जी व्हेन जब सिस्टम पावर्स ऑन
जैसे आपका सिस्टम पावर्स ऑन होता है इट
मस्ट मेंटेन एक्यूरेट टाइमिंग
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन फॉर द सीपीयू रम एंड अदर
कंपोनेंट्स दिस इज वेयर द रियल टाइम क्लॉक
एंड द क्लॉक जनरेटर कम इन टू प्ले अभी
आपने देखा होगा कि आप अपनी मशीन को स्विच
ऑफ कर देते हो प्लग आउट कर देते हो अपनी
मशीन को लेकिन नेक्स्ट डे या जब भी आप
अपनी मशीन को ऑन करते हो तो आपको जो भी
डेट और टाइम लेटेस्ट डेट और टाइम जो चल
रहा होता है वही मिलता है उसके लिए भी तो
कुछ ना कुछ रिस्पांसिबल होता है ना तो वही
चीज है कि जैसे आप पावर ऑन करते हो तो वो
चीज कि जो भी प्रेजेंट डेट एंड टाइम है व
उसके साथ क्या करता है सिंक्रोनाइज करता
है आपका पावर ऑन के साथ ही अभी उसके लिए
रिस्पांसिबल होती है दो चीजें मेनली एक
चीज है डेट और टाइम के लिए आपका रियल टाइम
क्लॉक जो आपके इसके अंदर लगा होता है मदर
बोर्ड के अंदर उसके बाद क्लॉक जनरेटर का
अपना काम होता है और दोनों एक साथ काम
करते हैं इनका क्या काम है मैं आपको बताता
हूं व्हाट इज द रियल टाइम क्लॉक आरटीसी
क्या होती है द रियल टाइम क्लॉक इज ए
बैटरी पावर चिप आपको देखने को मिल रहा
होगा सी मोस्ट बैटरी करके ओके तो ये है
आपकी रियल टाइम क्लॉक रियल टाइम क्लॉक इज
ए बैटरी पावर चिप ऑन द मदरबोर्ड दैट
मेंटेन द सिस्टम्स डेट एंड टाइम इवन व्हेन
द कंप्यूटर इज पावर ऑफ अगर आपका जो पीसी
है आपकी जो मशीन अगर पावर ऑफ है स्विच ऑफ
है तब भी क्या करता है यह आपके डेट और
टाइम को मेंटेन करता है क्योंकि आपके मदर
बोर्ड में एक सीमो बैटरी लगी हुई थी इट इज
इंडिपेंडेंट फ्रॉम द मेन सिस्टम पावर
सप्लाई इसे मेन सिस्टम पावर सप्लाई मिले
ना मिले उससे इंडिपेंडेंट है आपके मदर में
एक स्माल कॉइन सेल बैटरी लगी होती है
cr2032 अभी बदल गई होगी एंड ये एक फिक्स्ड
फ्रीक्वेंसी पर रन करता है नॉर्मली एक
एग्जांपल है 32 प व्हाट एवर ये आपसे आपको
मतलब नहीं है एंड स्टोर्स डेट टाइम डेट
टाइम एंड डेट एंड बायोस एंड यूईएफआई
सेटिंग्स ओके जो आपके बायोस है और जो यूएफ
आई सेटिंग्स है वो इसी के अंदर स्टोर करके
रखता है समझ में आया कि ये हमेशा आपकी
पावर सप्लाई हो या ना हो लेकिन यह जो सेल
है इसके अंदर हमेशा आपके डेट और टाइम और
साथ में बायो सेटिंग सेव रहती है जो हमेशा
एक्टिव रहता है ये कभी भी स्लीप नहीं होता
अगर जिस दिन ये स्लीप हो गया इसकी बैटरी
डेड होगी उस दिन क्या होगा आपके सिस्टम की
बायोस में प्रॉब्लम आ जाएगी या अपलोड जो
फर्मवेयर एग्जीक्यूट करने में प्रॉब्लम आ
जाएगी दूसरा या टाइम सिंक्रोनाइज नहीं
होगा अभी व्हाट इज द क्लॉक जनरेटर क्लॉक
जनरेटर का क्या काम होता है द क्लॉक
जनरेटर इज ए क्रुशल मदरबोर्ड कंपोनेंट दैट
प्रोड्यूस प्रोसाइज टाइमिंग सिग्नल्स फॉर
वेरियस हार्ड हार्डवेयर कंपोनेंट्स इट
इंश्योर दैट द सीपीयू रम जीपीयू एंड
पीसीआई डिवाइस ऑपरेट एट द करेक स्पीड अभी
सबको पता है कि जब भी आप पीसी खरीदते हो
आपने एक देखा होगा कि
उसकी फीचर्स में देखा हुआ क्लॉक स्पीड 3
गगा हर्ज टू 4.9 गह 5 गज या 5 गज वो आपने
फ्रीक्वेंसी देखी होगी वो क्या है वो एक
क्लॉक स्पीड होती है अभ ये क्लॉक स्पीड
होती क्या है और क्यों जरूरी होती है तो
जैसे-जैसे हम अपने फंडामेंटल्स में आगे
बढ़ेंगे एक स्टोरी के साथ तो आपको सब
क्लियर आ जाएगी कि ओके हमारे सिस्टम्स में
जो एप्लीकेशंस रन कर रही हैं और यह क्लॉक
स्पीड है इसका क्या आपस में रिलेशन है यह
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा तो अभी के लिए समझ
में आया कि ये जो क्लॉक जनरेटर है इस
स्पीड को मेंटेन करवाता है ठीक है क्योंकि
सीपीयू रम जीपीयू भी एक ही क्या करते हैं
फ्रीक्वेंसी पर काम करते हैं सिंक्रोनाइज
होके एक टाइम एंड डेट पर एक साथ एक ही
टाइमिंग पर एक ही डेट पर क्या कि पूरा
सिंक्रोनाइज होके काम करना तो इन दोनों को
साथ में काम करना हो किसको आरटीसी को और
क्लॉक जनरेटर को द क्लॉक जनरेटर इंश्योर
दैट ऑल सिस्टम कंपोनेंट्स ऑपरेट एट द
करेक्ट टाइमिंग फ्रीक्वेंसी ओके आपको बता
है सीपीयू एंड मदरबोर्ड ऑपरेट बेस्ड ऑन ए
फिक्स्ड क्लॉक स्पीड वो एक फिक्स्ड क्लॉक
स्पीड पर काम करते हैं यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है
यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है नहीं क्वालिटी अपडेट हो रही है यार
मैंने अभी अभी जस्ट आपके सामने 1080 की है
क्वालिटी अपडेट हो
गई तो आगे चले
प्लीज चैट में सभी बताइए यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है सबको क्लास में मजा आ रहा है
बूटिंग प्रोसेस में मजा आ रहा है इट विल
टेक टाइम काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है आपको मजा
आएगा बहुत सारी चीजें इतनी क्लियर हो
जाएंगी आपके सामने की बिल्कुल क्रिस्टल
एंड
क्लियर दे 19 स्टूडेंट्स ओनली वेरी गुड आज
भी स्टूडेंट्स नहीं आ सकते तो कुछ नहीं कह
सकते ओके तो नेक्स्ट अभी आगे बढ़ते हैं एट
दिस स्टेज इन द बूट प्रोसेस अभी यहां तक
क्या हुआ कि जो क्लॉक सिंक्रोनाइज होगी
हमारा और जो क्लॉक जनरेटर एक फ्रीक्वेंसी
जनरेट कर दी क्योंकि वहां तक सिग्नल ओके
है तो दिस स्टेज इस बूट जो बूट प्रोसेस
में दस सीपीयू वेक्स अप एंड बिगिंस
एग्जीक्यूशन फ्रॉम ए प्री डिफाइंड मेमोरी
एड्रेस कॉल्ड द रिसेट वेक्टर अभी क्या
होगा कि जब आपके मदरबोर्ड में पावर सप्लाई
आ गई उसके बाद आपके सीपीयू के पास भी पावर
सप्लाई जाएगी और जैसे ही सीपीय के पास
पावर सप्लाई जाएगी तो आपका जो सीपीयू है
सेंट्रल प्रोसेसिंग यूनिट एक चिप होती है
वो वेकअप एंड एग्जीक्यूशन स्टार्ट करेगी
कहां से एक प्री डिफाइंड मेमोरी एड्रेस से
जिसको हम रिसेट वेक्टर बोलते हैं अब ये
क्या क्या होता है मैं आपको समझाऊ दिस
स्टेप इज क्रुशल बिकॉज इट इनिला इजस द
प्रोसेसर एंड बिगिंस फेचिंग इंस्ट्रक्शन
टू स्टार्ट द सिस्टम अभी ये और भी ज्यादा
क्रुशल प्रोसेस है क्योंकि यहां पर जो
प्रोसेसेस है वो स्टार्ट हो जाती है इनिश
इइ होना स्टार्ट हो जाती है साथ के साथ जो
इंस्ट्रक्शंस है कि मुझे अभी आगे क्या
करना है वो फैच करना स्टार्ट कर देता है
आपका सीपीयू बट रुको अभी यहां पर एक चीज
जो आपको मैं समझाता हूं व्हाट हैपेंस
ड्यूरिंग सीपीयू वेकअप
अभी सीपीयू वेकअप में होता क्या है वन द
पावर इज अप्लाइड जब भी सीपीयू के पास जो
सेंट्रल प्रोसेसिंग यूनिट की जो चिप उसके
पास पावर आती है या पावर सप्लाई की जाती
है द सीपीयू डज नॉट इमीडिएट स्टार्ट
एग्जीक्यूटिंग इंस्ट्रक्शन सीपीयू तुरंत
जो भी इंस्ट्रक्शंस को है वो इमीडिएट
इंस्ट्रक्शन पर एग्जीक्यूट करना स्टार्ट
नहीं कर देता की बजाय इट गोज थ्रू एन
इंटरनल वेकअप एंड इनिला
प्रोसेस डायरेक्टली इंस्ट्रक्शन को फैच
करने की बजाय उसके पास भी एक इनिश इजेशन
प्रोसेस है एक इनिश इजेशन सीक्वेंस है जो
उसके
इंटरनल उसका पार्ट है मतलब चेक ऑफ लिस्ट
का पार्ट है वो उसको फॉलो करेगा तभी वह
क्या करेगा अपने इंस्ट्रक्शंस को
एग्जीक्यूट करना स्टार्ट करेगा अभी वो
कौन-कौन सी कुछ चेक लिस्ट है जो सीपीयू की
वो क्या-क्या करता है सबसे पहले स्टेप वन
में क्या करता है पावर ऑन पावर ऑन सेल्फ
चेक क्या करता है पावर ऑन सेल्फ चेक करता
है बिल्ड इन सीपीओ डायग्नोसिस इसमें क्या
करता है सीपीयू वेरीफाई द इंटीग्रिटी ऑफ
इट्स इंटरनल कंपोनेंट्स बिफोर
एग्जीक्यूटिंग एनी इंस्ट्रक्शन क्योंकि
सबसे पहले क्या करता है कि जो सीपीयू है
जो चिप लगी है व अपनी हेल्थ को भी चेक
करती है कि मैं मुझे जो इंस्ट्रक्शन
क्योंकि सबसे पावरफुल यूनिट क्या है आपके
सीपीयू की मतलब आपके जो कंप्यूटर की
सीपीयू है प्रोसेसिंग यूनिट तो उसको अपनी
हेल्थ भी चेक करनी होगी कि जो भी उसके
अंदर कंपोनेंट्स लगे हुए हैं वो सारे सही
से काम कर रहे हैं या नहीं कर रहे तो वही
चीज है इट चेक्स फॉर फल्ट इन इंटरनल
सर्किट उसका इंटरनल जो सर्किट है उसमें
कोई फल्ट तो नहीं है या सही से काम कर रहा
नहीं कर रहा उसके अंदर एलय होते हैं सारे
एलय सही से काम कर रहे हैं एफपीयू
फ्लोटिंग पॉइंट यूनिट इंस्ट्रक्शन
पाइपलाइन कैच मेमोरी कंट्रोल यूनिट व्हाट
एवर द कंपोनेंट्स ऑफ द सीपीयू सेंट्रल
प्रोसेसिंग जो चिप है उसके जो भी
कंपोनेंट्स है सबकी फंक्शन चेक करता है कि
सारे काम कर रहे हैं या नहीं ये चीज इफ
एनी कंपोनेंट फेल्स अगर कोई भी कंपोनेंट
क्या करता है फेल हो जाता है सीपीयू विल
होल्ड एग्जीक्यूशन और फेलियर सिग्नल टू द
मदर मोड अगर कोई भी कंपोनेंट खराब है इस
चिप के अंदर तो यह क्या करता है अपना
एग्जीक्यूशन स्टॉप कर देता है और एक
फेलियर सिग्नल भेज देता मदर बोर्ड के पास
ओके मैं काम नहीं कर सकता जिससे आपका
सिस्टम फिर से बूट नहीं होगा सेकंड स्टेप
पे क्या चेक करता है आपका सीपीयू रिसेट
लाइन एक्टिवेशन चेक करता है इसका मतलब
क्या होता है व्हेन द सिस्टम इज फर्स्ट
पावर ऑन जब सबसे पहले सिस्टम को पावर ऑन
किया जाता है सीपीयू इज हेल्ड इन ए रिसेट
स्टेट सीपीयू को मदर बोर्ड के द्वारा
रिसेट स्टेट में रखा जाता है मतलब एक
फ्रिज स्टेज में मतलब आपका सीपीयू अभी जो
प्रोसेसिंग यूनिट है चिप है वो काम नहीं
कर रही उसका एक कारण है द मदरबोर्ड यूज ए
रिसेट सिग्नल क्योंकि जो चिप लगी हुई है
उसके अंदर एक पिन होती है उस पिन में क्या
करता है ये वो मदर बोर्ड क्या करर है उस
वैल्यू चेंज कर देता है उसकी वैल्यू क्या
कर देता है जीरो कर देता है मतलब उसके पास
कोई भी सिग्नल अभी तक नहीं जा रहा
एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए या उसको काम करने के
लिए चिप के पार तो मदरबोर्ड यूजिस ए रिसेट
सिग्नल एक्टिव लॉ टू प्रिवेंट एग्जीक्यूशन
अंट्टी बलाइज जब तक पावर स्टेबलाइज नहीं
हो जाती जब तक पावर स्टेबल नहीं हो जाती
आपके मदर बोर्ड के अंदर तब तक इसकी जो
वैल्यू है उसको चेंज नहीं किया जाता
मदरबोर्ड चिपसेट कीप्स द सीपीयू इन ए
रिसेट स्टेट बाय होल्डिंग द रिसेट पिन लॉ
ओके 0 वोल्ट दिस मींस सीपीयू इज
इफेक्टिवली फ्रोजन एंड अनेबल टू
एग्जीक्यूट एनी इंस्ट्रक्शंस जब तक पावर
सप्लाई आपकी स्टेबल नहीं रहेगी तब तक आपका
जो है वो फ्रिज मोड में रहेगा फ्रोजन एंड
वो कोई भी इंस्ट्रक्शन को एग्जीक्यूट नहीं
कर सकता दिस इंश्योर दैट सीपीयू डज नॉट रन
अनस्टेबल इंस्ट्रक्शन ड्यू टू पावर
फ्लक्शनल यह इंश्योर करता है कि अगर पावर
फ्लक्शनल में आपका सीपीयू किसी भी
इंस्ट्रक्शन को फैच नहीं करहा क्योंकि
इससे माल फंक्शनिंग होने के चांसेस हैं
वंस पावर इज फुल्ली स्टेबल द क्लॉक जनरेटर
इज रनिंग अगर आपकी पावर और एक बार स्टेबल
हो जाती है क्लॉक जनरेटर रनिंग है तो
मदरबोर्ड डी डी असर्ट्स द रिसेट सिग्नल
बाय पुलिंग इट हाई तो जो रिसेट सिग्नल
उसको फिर से क्या करता है उसको चेंज कर
देता हाई में रख देता मतलब उसको रिसेट
स्टेट से हटा देता है देन सीपीयू फैच द
फर्स्ट इंस्ट्रक्शन फ्रॉम द रिसेट वेक्टर
उस केस में क्या होता है जब रिसेट स्टेट
से सीपीयू नॉर्मल स्टेट में आता है मतलब
रनिंग के लिए एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए रेडी
होता है तब सबसे पहले जो फर्स्ट
इंस्ट्रक्शन जो फेच करता है म मतलब मुझे
क्या करना है कहां से मुझे कौन से एड्रेस
से मुझे अपने काम स्टार्ट करना है वो
फर्स्ट इंस्ट कहां से फैक्स करता है आपके
रिसेट वेक्टर से अभी रिसेट वेक्टर क्या
होता है वो भी मैं आपको बताऊंगा व्हाट इफ
पावर इज अनस्टेबल अगर आपकी पावर अनस्टेबल
होगी तो क्या होगा द सीपीयू रिमेंस रिसेट
मोड सिफ हमेशा क्या होगा आपके रिसेट मोड
में रहेगा इफ पावर इज इनकंसिस्टेंट
इनकंसिस्टेंट तो द सिस्टम मे एक्सपीरियंस
कंटीन्यूअस रिपोट जिसकी वजह से क्या हो
सकता है आपका सिस्टम कंटीन्यूअसली या तो
रिपोट करेगा या आप का बूट होगा ही नहीं
कोई ब्लैक स्क्रीन आपको देखने को मिलेगी
और आपको समझ में आएगा ही नहीं ओके नेक्स्ट
स्टेप थ्री में क्या चेक करता है
आपका सीपीयू क्लॉक सिंक्रोनाइजेशन करता है
आपका सीपीयू क्या करता है नेक्स्ट स्टेप
में क्लॉक सिंक्रोनाइजेशन दी क्लॉक जनरेटर
चिप प्रोवाइड ए टाइमिंग सिग्नल टू द
सीपीयू ओके और द सीपीयू लाइंग इट्स इंटरनल
एग्जीक्यूशन स्पीड विद द एक्सटर्नल बेस
क्लॉक मैंने बताया था क्योंकि गीगाहर्टज
में ऑपरेट करते हैं तो ये क्या करता है
अपनी फ्रीक्वेंसी ें को मैच करते हैं कि
मुझे इस फ्रीक्वेंसी से रन करना होगा
क्लॉक सिंक्रोनाइजेशन यहां पर होता है जो
फोर्थ स्टेप होता है वहां पर रजिस्टर्स
एंड कैचेज आर क्लियर मतलब क्या होता है कि
जो आपका जो सीपीयूज है सीपीयूज के अंदर
बहुत सारे रजिस्टर्स होते हैं बहुत सारे
रजिस्टर्स होते हैं बेसिकली तो उनको क्या
करता है क्लियर करता है मतलब जो जनरल
पर्पस रजिस्टर्स है उनको इनिला करता है
फ्लोटिंग पॉइंट रजिस्टर को इनिला करता है
उसके अंदर एक इंस्ट्रक्शन पॉइंटर रजिस्टर
होता है इंस्ट्रक्शन पॉइंट मतलब जहां से
मुझे एजट करना है अपनी कमांड्स को
इंस्ट्रक्शंस को उस उसके बाद एमएमयू होती
है l1 ए2 ए3 कैच सबको क्या करता है अभी
इनिश इइ करना स्टार्ट कर देता है जो
इंस्ट्रक्शन पॉइंटर होता है इस सेट टू
हार्ड कोडेड रिसेट वेक्टर एड्रेसस अभी जो
इंस्ट्रक्शन पॉइंट होता है उस उस पर क्या
होती है कि रिसेट वेक्टर एड्रेस होता
रिसेट वेक्टर के अंदर होता है एक मेमोरी
एड्रेस होता है उसको हार्ड कोडेड करके रखा
जाता है स्टोर करके रखा जाता है एंड द
सीपीयू जंप्स टू दिस एड्रेस टू फैस द
फर्स्ट इंस्ट्रक्शन फ्रॉम द फर्मवेयर उसके
बाद जैसे ही आप आपका सीपीय इनिला होता है
आपका जो रिचर्च स्टेटस स्टेट से हटा दिया
जाता है मदर बोर्ड के द्वारा पावर स्टेबल
होने के बाद उसके बाद क्या करता है व
डायरेक्टली इस इंस्ट्रक्शन पॉइंटर पर जाता
है और अपनी सबसे पहला जो इंस्ट्रक्शन है
उसको फैच करता है और जो किसकी होती है
आपके फर्मवेयर की होती है ओके बायोस या जो
यूएफ आई होती है जो फर्मवेयर होता है उसकी
सबसे पहले इंस्ट्रक्शन होती है उसको फैच
करता है
नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं कि ये रिसेट
वेक्टर होता क्या है यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है रिट वेक्टर तक यहां तक सबको समझ में आ
रहा
है सबको क्लियर है यहां तक सबको समझ में आ
रहा है
फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ विंडोज में आपके इतने
बेसिक लेवल की चीजें आएंगी जो शायद एज ए
पेंटेस्टर्स आपको बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है और
आपको उस लेवल पर मैं फंडामेंटल डिलीवर
करूंगा उसके बाद आप कभी भी
बहुत सारे बेसिक कांसेप्ट है जो मैं आपको
क्लियर
करूंगा तो आई थिंक हम आगे बढ़ना चाहिए तो
रिसेट वेक्टर के बारे में समझते हैं तो
जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स है प्लीज रिप्लाई
कीजिए अगर कोई आपकी क्वेरी है तो मुझसे
पूछ सकते हो साथ के साथ खासकर जब मैं आपसे
पूछता हूं तो अभी रिसेट वेक्टर क्या होता
है रिसेट वेक्टर इज ए स्पेसिफिक मेमोरी
एड्रेस एक स्पेसिफिक मेमोरी एड्रेस होता
है वेयर द सीपीयू एक्सपेक्ट टू फाइंड द
फर्स्ट इंस्ट्रक्शन आफ्टर पावर ऑन और
रिसेट ओके एक ऐसी स्पेस एक मेमोरी एड्रेस
होता है जहां से आपका सीपीयू सबसे पहली
इंस्ट्रक्शन लेता है कि जैसे मैं पावर ऑन
होगा पावर ऑन हो जाऊंगा जैसे मेरे को पावर
सप्लाई मिल जाएगी और मुझे अपना
एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए परमिशन मिल जाएगी तो
मैं सबसे पहले कहां से स्टार्ट करूंगा
उसका मेमोरी एड्रेस रहता है तो वेयर इज द
रिसेट वेक्टर लोकेटेड ये रिसेट वेक्टर
कहां पर लोकेटेड रहता है तो मॉडर्न जो x86
सिस्टम्स होते हैं जो रिसेट वेक्टर की
वैल्यू होती है वो ये होती है ओके ये
हार्ड कोडेड रहती है दिस लोकेशन इज
टिपिकली मैप टू u5 फ्रेम वेयर फर्मवेयर
ओके अब ये लोकेशंस होती है आपकी जो ये
एड्रेस है ये आपका किसके साथ मैप है यूआ
फर्मवेयर से मैप होता है अब जो बायोस है
या आपका यूआ प्लेस प्लेसेस ए स्मॉल जंप
इंस्ट्रक्शन अब इसके ऊपर क्या करते हैं
अपने जो फर्मवेयर के अंदर वो एक स्मॉल जंप
इं अ जंप इंस्ट्रक्शन क्या है आपकी मशीन
लैंग्वेज की एक टर्मिनोलॉजी है तो स्किप
कीजिए बस समझिए ओनली कि एक स्मॉल जंप
इंस्ट्रक्शन रखता है वहां पर उस एड्रेस के
ऊपर एंड जो क्या पॉइंट करेगा आपके जो मेन
कोड आपका जो बायोस के अंदर या जो आपका
यूएफ आई फम फर्मवेयर का जो मेन कोड है जो
मेन एग्जीक्यूशन कोड है उसके ऊपर पॉइंट
करेगा एक जंप इंस्ट्रक्शन जैसे आप इस
एड्रेस प जाओगे फिजिकल एड्रेस पे वहां पर
एक जंप इंस्ट्रक्शन होगी आप डायरेक्टली
क्या करोगे उस फ्रॉम वेयर कोड पे चले
जाओगे और जहां से आप क्या करोगे अपना
एग्जीक्यूशन स्टार्ट कर दोगे तो बायोस और
यूएफ आई फर्मवेयर एग्जीक्यूशन बिगिंस एंड
लोडिंग लो लेवल हार्डवेयर इनिला इजेशन
रूटीन उसके बाद जैसे ही आप उस एड्रेस प
जाते हो और आपका जो बायस ऑफ फर्मवेयर के
अंदर जो कोड है वो एग्जीक्यूट होना
स्टार्ट हो जाता है अभी तक तो देखो हम
स्टेप वन में है आप सोचिए कि कुछ सेकंडो
में कितनी सारी चीजें होती है आपके सीपीयू
के अंदर कितनी सारी चीजें जब मतलब आप जस्ट
आपने पावर ऑन बटन प्रेस किया कुछ मिली
सेकंड में कुछ सेकंड्स में क्या होता है
आपकी सिस्टम्स पे एक लॉगइन स्क्रीन आ जाती
है तो इतनी फास्ट यह सारी चीजें हो रही थ
है अभी तो मैं सेकंड स्टेप पे आया ही नहीं
हूं अब फर्स्ट स्टेप पे हम ओके तो ये सारी
चीजें होती है तो आई थिंक कि रिसेट वेक्टर
क्या होता है आपको मैंने क्लियर कर दिया
एक मेमोरी एड्रेस होता है जो क्या करता है
किसका एड्रेस होता है आपके यूएफ आ
फर्मवेयर का एड्रेस होता है और उसके अंदर
एक जंप इंस्ट्रक्शन होती है जो मेन जो
फर्मवेयर कोड होता है उसकी तरफ पॉइंट करती
है जहां से हमारा सीपीयू क्या करेगा
इंस्ट्रक्शन लेना स्टार्ट करेगा और अपने
बूटिंग सीक्वेंस को स्टार्ट कर देगा बूट
अप करना स्टार्ट कर देगा ओके नेक्स्ट अभी
हम बात करते हैं वंस सीपीयू रिसीव पावर जब
एक बार आपके सीपीयू को पावर मिल जाती है
स्टेबलाइज इटस क्लॉक उसकी क्लॉक स्टेबलाइज
हो जाती है एंड एग्जिट द रिसेट स्टेट और
अपनी रिसेट स्टेट से बाहर आ जाता है इट
बिगिंस एग्जीक्यूटिंग इंस्ट्रक्शन फ्रॉम द
रिसेट वेक्टर और वो क्या करता है जो रिसेट
वेक्टर है रिसेट वेक्टर मैंने आपको बता
दिया एक फिक्स एड्रेस होता है उससे क्या
करता है अपनी इंस्ट्रक्शन एग्जीक्यूट करना
स्टार्ट कर देता है रिसेट वेक्टर क्या है
एक फिक्स मेमोरी एड्रेस पॉइंट टू द
फर्मवेयर स्टोर्ड इन द बायोस और यूएफ आई
चिप अभी जो बायोस और यूएफ आ फर्मवेयर
स्टार्ट एग्जीक्यूटिंग अभी क्या हो गया कि
आपके मदर बोर्ड के अंदर भी एक बायो शिप
होती है ओके अभी जो आजकल लेटेस्ट जो अ
मदरबोर्ड्स आ रहे हैं उसमें एपीआई एक चिप
है एपीआई फ्लैश रोम करके सीरियल पेरिफेरल
इंटरफेस फ्लैश मेमोरी करके इस टाइप कोई भी
जैसे मेरी आप इमेज में आपको देखने को मि
इस टाइप की कोई चिप है जो अंदर लगे हुए
जिसके अंदर आपका बायोस कोड भी है ओके तो द
फर्मवेयर कोड इज स्टोर्ड इन द एपीआई फ्लैश
रोम ऑन द मदर बोर्ड मदर बोर्ड के ऊपर द
फर्स्ट जॉब ऑफ द फर्मवेयर इज टू इनिला इज
बेसिक हार्डवेयर एंड प्रिपेयर द सिस्टम
फॉर बूटिंग बूटिंग ओके अभी जो बायोस है
फर्मवेयर होता है फर्मवेयर होता क्या है
इसको भी मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करूंगा लेकिन
इसका जो प्राइमरी जॉब है आपके जो बायोस की
वो प्राइमरी जॉब है कि जो हार्डवेयर है
उसको इनिला इज करना और सिस्टम को बूटिंग
प्रोसेस के लिए रेडी करना तो आई थिंक यहां
तक किसी कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ सकते
हो यस आई विल एक्सप्लेन फ्रॉम वेर डोंट
वरी तो नेक्स्ट स्लाइड में आपको एक्सप्लेन
कर दूंगा तो यहां तक किसी का कोई डाउट है
तो मुझसे पूछ सकते हो प्लीज पूछिए आप
लोगों अगर चीज समझ में नहीं आई तो मुझसे
आप पूछ सकते
हो सबका क्लियर यहां तक तो यह बायोस और यफ
आई फर्मवेयर क्या होता है फर्मवेयर
एक्चुअल में होता क्या है यह मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन कर यहां से जो कहानी स्टार्ट
होगी वह भी हम कंटिन्यू
करेंगे हां माइकल माइकल क्या होता है कि
जब मैं आपको एक काम करता हूं कि मैं नहीं
चाहता शायद आप कंफ्यूज हो जाओ अदर वाइज
अगर मैं अटैक की बात करूं तो हर लेवल पर
हार्डवेयर अटैक पॉसिबल है फर्मवेयर लेवल
पर भी बायोस सीमस लेवल पर भी हर लेवल पर
हार्डवेयर पॉसिबल है हार्डवेयर अटैक
पॉसिबल
से
ओके नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं यह फर्मवेयर
होता क्या है फर्मवेयर इज ए लो लेवल
सॉफ्टवेयर एंबेडेड इन हार्डवेयर दैट एक्ट
एज एन इंटरफेस बिटवीन द सिस्टम हार्डवेयर
एंड हायर लेवल सॉफ्टवेयर लाइक द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम बेसिकली क्या होता है कि जो आपका
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एक
कोड है और जो आपका हार्डवेयर्स हैं उनके
बीच में इंटरफेस का काम करता है आपका
फर्मवेयर फर्मवेयर भी एक प्रकार से एक
सॉफ्टवेयर है सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम है
जिसके अंदर बहुत सारी इंस्ट्रक्शंस हैं कि
क्या-क्या करना है तो समझ में आया जैसे
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या है एप्लीकेशंस और
आपके हार्डवेयर के बीच में कमिट करने के
लिए ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का यूज किया जाता है
ऐसे ही ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से और हार्डवेयर
के बीच में कम्युनिकेशन किसके थ्रू किया
जाता है आपका फर्मवेयर के थ्रू ही किया
जाता है तो फर्मवेयर एक क्या है एक लो
लेवल सॉफ्टवे होता है जो किसी एक
हार्डवेयर के अंदर एंबेड करके राइट करके
रख दिया जाता है दिस फर्मवेयर इज
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर इनिश इजिंग हार्डवेयर
कंपोनेंट एंड बूटिंग द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
अभी ये जो फर्मवेयर है आपके हार्डवेयर
कंपोनेंट को इनिला इज करने के लिए और
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को बूट करने के लिए
रिस्पांसिबल होता है एंड व्हाट इज द
प्राइमरी पर्पस ऑफ फर्मवेयर किसी भी
फर्मवेयर का प्राइमरी पर्पस क्या होता है
बूट स्टप अब ये बूट स्टेप क्या होता है
बूट स्टप इज द फर्स्ट एग्जीक्यूटेड
सॉफ्टवेयर ऑन एडि डिटल डिवाइस किसी भी
डिजिटल डिवाइस पर जो सबसे पहला जो
हार्डवेयर के बाद चाहे मैं स्मार्ट टीवी
की बात करूं चाहे मैं अपने पर्सनल
कंप्यूटर की बात करूं चाहे मैं अपने ऑटो
मोबाइल्स के जितने भी मशीनस हैं सबकी मैं
बात करूं हार्डवेयर के बाद सबसे पहला जो
सॉफ्टवेयर एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है जो भी
सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम रन किया जाता है
डिजिटल डिवाइस के ऊपर उसको हम बोलते हैं
बूट स्टैप कोड इसी प्रकार से फर्मवेयर के
आपका एक बूट स्टैप कोड होता है समझ में
आया कि बूट स्टैप इज द फर्स्ट
एग्जीक्यूटेड सॉफ्टवेयर ऑन ए डिजिटल
डिवाइस वेदर इट इज अ स्मार्ट टीवी पीसी और
योर ऑटोमोबाइल द फर्स्ट सॉफ्टवेयर दैट
गेट्स एग्जीक्यूटेड बाय द हार्डवेयर इज
कॉल्ड द बूट स्टैप कोड तो फ्रॉम वेयर इन द
चिप बिगिंस द बिगिंस टू बी एग्जीक्यूटेड
बाय द सीपीयू व्हेन यू पावर ऑफ द मदरबोर्ड
अभी आपका जो फर्मवेयर है जो बूट स्टेप कोड
है उसको एक चिप में स्टोर करके आपके मदर
बोर्ड में प्लांट कर दिया गया है और जैसे
ही आपका सीपीयू पावर अप होता है मदर बोर्ड
के द्वारा वह क्या करता है आपके फर्मवेयर
की इंस्ट्रक्शन पर जाता है और आपके सिस्टम
को बूट करना स्टार्ट कर देता है तो सबको
समझ में आया फर्मवेयर क्या होता है अगर
आपसे कोई फर्मवेयर पूछता है तो आप इस
तरीके से बता सकते हो कि फर्मवेयर क्या
होता है एक बूट स्टप होता है बूट स्टेप
क्या होता है कि हार्डवेयर कंपोनेंट के
बाद सबसे पहला जो सॉफ्टवेयर होता है जो
एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है आपके सिस्टम मशीन
के ऊपर उसको हम बोल सकते
हैं डिजिटल डिवाइस बोल सकते हो उसको हम
बोलते हैं बूट स्ट्रैप कोड ओके और बूट
स्टैप कोड को हम क्या बोल सकते हैं
फर्मवेयर बोल सकते हैं एवरीवन गट
क्लियर यस सी माउस में होता है आपका फ्रॉम
वेयर और आजकल क्या है कि उसका भी
इंस्ट्रक्शन पास कर दिया है आजकल शायद एक
अलग से यह चिप लगा दी गई है जो मैंने अभी
लास्ट इसमें बताया था आपका एसबीआई फ्लैश
रोम तो यहां तक सबको को क्लियर आई थिंक कि
फम वेयर क्या होता है अभी फम वेयर से
रिलेटेड आपका कोई डाउट नहीं होना चाहिए अब
स्टेप टू पे चले ये हमारा स्टेप वन था मैं
आपको अभी और एक्सप्लेन कर देता हूं अभी तक
हुआ क्या है कि देखिए हमने पावर बटन को
प्रेस किया यहां से एक सिग्नल गया पीएसयू
के पास पीएसयू ने अपना सेल्फ टेस्ट किया
सेल्फ टेस्ट करने के बाद ओके उसको जितनी
पावर सप्लाई चाहिए थी वो स्टेबल पावर
सप्लाई मिल रही है उसने क्या कर दिया
एक पीजी सिग्नल क्या कि पावर गुड सिग्नल
किसके पास भेज दिया मदर बोर्ड के पास अब
मदरबोर्ड के पास भी रम है जीपीयू है आपके
एसएसडी है सीपीयू है दे और अदर कंपोनेंट्स
आर अवेलेबल सबको पावर सप्लाई चाहिए तो ये
भी क्या करता है कि इसके अंदर एक वोल्टेज
रेगुलेटर होता है और सभी को क्या करता है
एक स्टेबल पावर सप्लाई पास करता है और
उसके अंदर क्या होता है सीमस बैटरी लगी
होती है जिसमें क्या है कि और अलग से इस
तरीके से क्लॉक जनरेटर होता है कुछ इस तरह
की चिप आपको देखने को मिलती है क्लॉक
जनरेटर क्या करता है जैसे उसको पावर
सप्लाई मिलती है वो अपनी फ्रीक्वेंसी
जनरेट करना स्टार्ट कर देता है सी मोस
बैटरी ऑलरेडी चल ही होती है लेकिन वो क्या
करती है सबको क्या डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर है टाइम
एंड डेट डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर है सारे कंपोनेंट
को उसके बाद ये आपका क्या है आपका यूएफ आई
और जो आपका फर्मवेयर है ये भी क्या करता
है एग्जीक्यूट होना स क्योंकि सीपीओ जैसे
पावर सप्लाई मिली स्टेबल पावर सप्लाई मिली
सीपीओ क्या करेगा सबसे पहले जाएगा आपके
यूएफ आई कोड के ऊपर फर्मवेयर के ऊपर और
वहां से इंस्ट्रक्शन लेना स्टार्ट कर देगा
तो अभी तक हमने सिर्फ यह क्या किया है
अपने जो यूएफ आई है जो आपका बायोस है वहां
तक हमने पहुंचा अभी स्टेप वन कंप्लीट किया
कि हमें पावर सप्लाई मिल गी सीपीय को को
इंस्ट्रक्शन मिल गई है सीपी को रिसेट
वेक्टर से एक मेमोरी एड्रेस मिल गया वहां
से उसको एड्रेस मिला कि ये हमारा यूआई के
अंदर एक फर्मवेयर कोड है यहां से अभी मुझे
क्या करना है बूटिंग सीक्वेंस स्टार्ट
करना है अपने सिस्टम को बूट करना स्टार्ट
करना है वहां से उसको इंस्ट्रक्शन मिल
चुकी है तो शायद यहां तक अभी किसी का कोई
डाउट नहीं होना
चाहिए भाई इतना डीप आपको कहीं नहीं मिलेगा
कोई आपको इतना डीप नहीं पढ़ाने
वाला आपको इतना खासकर बा बूट सीक्वेंस
नहीं पढ़ाने
वाला और खासकर एथिकल हैकिंग में तो
बिल्कुल कोई नहीं पढ़ाने
वाला और किसी ने अगर पढ़ा हो इतना डीप तो
मुझको बता सकता है कि शायद मैं भी पढ़ लू
कभी किसी से मुझे भी अगर एडवांस नॉलेज
चाहिए इसके ऊपर अगर और ज्यादा डीप नॉलेज
चाहिए तो बता सकते हो हो सकता है किसी ने
पढ़ाया भी हो बट जहां तक मुझे पता है इतना
डीप कोई नहीं
पढ़ाता प्लीज बताइए
चलिए नेक्स्ट स्टेप
पे ओके अभी हम नेक्स्ट स्टेप पर चलते हैं
स्टेप टू हमारा क्या होता है पावर ऑन
सेल्फ टेस्ट सभी ने पढ़ा होगा आज तक कि हम
सबसे पहला स्टेप वन क्या होता है हमारा
जैसे पावर सप्लाई करते हैं उसके बाद हमारा
क्या होता है सेकंड स्टेप क्या आता है
पोस्ट आपका जो मशीन है पावर बटन दबाते ही
आपको आपके मशीन के ऊपर इस तरीके से आपको
देखने मिलता है बायो स्क्रीन आपको इस
तरीके देखने को मिलती है कि बूट अप बूट अप
करना स्टार्ट कर देती है कुछ ऐसे f1 f2
प्रेस कीजिए ये पहले वाली मशीनों में ऐसे
आता था और अभी भी आती है स्टार्टिंग में
कुछ ठीक है ऐसे और अभी शायद नहीं आती तो
ये इस तरीके से आपको छोटे-छोटे कोड देखने
को मिलते थे तो ये क्या है आपकी बायो
स्क्रीन है ओके ये क्या आपका पोस्ट टेस्ट
है पावर ऑन सेल्फ टेस्ट होता है अभी तो
स्टेप वन में इतना कुछ हुआ उसके बाद उसके
बाद जब जैसे ही आपका सीपीयू इनिश हो जाता
है आपकी इंस्ट्रक्शन ले लेता है यूएफ आई
से फर्मवेयर से देन उसके बाद आपका पोस्ट
टेस्ट होता है पावर ऑन सेल्फ टेस्ट होता
है उसके बाद होता है लेकिन डायरेक्टली
आपको कैसे बताते हैं कि आपको जैसे पावर ऑन
बटन किया उसके बाद पोस्ट टेस्ट होगा पोस्ट
के बाद आपका बूटिंग सीक्वेंस स्टार्ट हो
जाएगा लेकिन कभी इतने बीच की जो इनके बीच
में क्या-क्या कहानी हुई है क्या-क्या काम
होता है कौन क्या कौन सा कंपोनेंट
क्या-क्या काम करता है वो सारी चीजें शायद
कोई नहीं बताता तो जैसे ही आपने पावर बटन
प्रेस किया जो पीसी फर्मवेयर इनिला इज
किया इनिला करता है क्या करता है पावर ऑन
सेल्फ टेस्ट एंड लोडस फर्मवेयर सेटिंग ये
दोनों काम एक साथ होते हैं द प्री बूट
प्रोसेस एंड्स व्हेन ए वैलिड सिस्टम डिस्क
इज डिटेक्टेड ओके और उसके बाद क्या होता
है कि जब आपको एक वैलिड डिस्क मिल जाती है
डिटेक्ट करने के लिए उसके बाद जो पावर ऑन
सेल्फ टेस्ट है ये कंप्लीट हो जाता है
पावर सेल्फ टेस्ट में क्या होता है आपके
हार्डवेयर सबको चेक किया जाता है ऑलरेडी
पहले चेक हो चुके है लेकिन ये सिंक्रोनाइज
करता है क्योंकि फर्मवेयर में लिखा हुआ है
उसके बाद ये पावर डिस्क सीपीयू क्लॉक
स्पीड सबको क्या करता है एक साथ फंक्शन टी
चेक करता है पावर ऑन पावर ऑन सेल्फ टेस्ट
इसको बोलते हैं अब आपका विजुअल क्लू किस
तरीके से आपको देखने को मिलता है इस तरीके
से आपको एक स्क्रीन देखने को मिलती है अभी
नेक्स्ट थर्ड स्टेप पे चलते हैं हम
नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा क्या होता है
लोकेटिंग द बूट डिवाइस एक बार जब आपका
पावर ऑन सेल्फ टेस्ट कंप्लीट हो जाता है
सक्सेसफुल हो जाता है ग्रीन सिग्नल है देन
उसके बाद क्या होता है आपके जो बूट डिवाइस
है हमारी मशीन मुझे बूट कहां से करना है
उसको लोकेट किया जा आफ्टर पोस्ट पावर ऑन
सेल्फ टेस्ट बायोस और यूईएफआई सर्च इज फॉर
ए बूटेबल डिवा डिवाइस कि आप अपने बूटेबल
डिवाइस को सर्च करते हैं अपने किससे इससे
फम फर्मवेयर के द्वारा कि मेरा बूटेबल
डिवाइस हार्ड डिस्क है या एसएसडी है
यूएसबी है सीडी है डीवीडी है या कोई
नेटवर्क डिवाइस है जहां से मुझे अपनी मशीन
को बूट करना है देन फ्रॉम वेयर चेक द बूट
ऑर्डर फ्रॉम वेर चेक द बूट ऑर्डर कन्फर्म
इन बायोस और यफ सेटिंग और बूट ऑर्डर को
चेक करता है वंस ए बूटेबल डिवाइस इज फाइड
जब उसको एक बार बूटेबल डिवाइस मिल जाती है
कि मुझे यूएसबी से बूट करना है या सीडी
डीवीडी नेटवर्क एसएसडी या हार्ड डिस्क
उसके बाद क्या होता है जो उसका जो कंट्रोल
है जो वो कंट्रोल किसको पास कर दिया जाता
है बूट लोडर को जो क्या कर रहा है इनको जो
मशीन को बूट करेगा उस बूट लोडर को क्या कर
दिया जाता है इस कंट्रोल को पास कर दिया
अभी तक कंट्रोल किसके पास था यूएफ आई के
पास था अभी उसके बूट लोडर के पास कंट्रोल
पास कर दिया था कंट्रोल दे दिया तो स्टेप
फोर में क्या होता है बूट लोडर
एग्जीक्यूशन अब बूट लोडर या तो एमबीआर या
जीपीटी के थ्रू ही होता है दो ही टाइप के
हैं पहले टाइम में एमबीआर यूज की जाती थी
लेकिन नाउ एडेज जीपीटी पार्टीशन का यूज
किया जाता है इफ सिस्टम यूज लेगासी बायोस
बहुत सारे सिस्टम्स हैं आज भी क्या कर रहे
हैं बायोस का यूज करते हैं रदर देन यूएफ
आई फ्रेम फर्मवेयर तो इफ सिस्टम यूज
लेगासी बायोस इट रीड्स द एमबीआर मास्टर
बूट रिकॉर्ड फ्रॉम द फर्स्ट 51 टू बाइट ऑफ
द डिस्क कि सबसे पहली बाइट होती है जो
डिस्क की उसमें क्या होता है आपका बूट
पार्टी सस होता है उसके अंदर सारी
इंस्ट्रक्शन रहती है इस मशीन को बूट करने
के लिए तो आपका जो जो बूट लोडर होता है
एमबीआर से क्या करता ह फर्स्ट 51 टू 12
बाइट से क्या करता है डिस्क को रीड करता
है ओके अगर आपका सिस्टम यूईएफआई यूज कर
रहा है इट रीड्स द जीपीटी पार्टीशन जीय
आईडी पार्टीशन टेबल को यूज रीड करता है
एंड एग्जीक्यूट द ईएफ आई बूट लोडर और ये
क्या करता है आपका यूई ईएफ आ बूट लोडर को
एग्जीक्यूट करता है तो दोनों ही केस में
अलग-अलग होता है लेकिन इसके बाद जो
सीक्वेंस स्टार्ट होता है देन कि जो
पार्टीशन टेबल अलग-अलग हो सकती है जीपीटी
हो सकती है या एमबीआर हो सकती है लेकिन
उसके बाद जो काम होता है जो फाइल लोड होनी
है और जो भी वर्किंग होनी है वो सेम होती
है दोनों के द्वारा दोनों के जो बूटिंग
सीक्वेंस अलग हो सकते हैं जैसे कि आपका जो
बूट एग्जीक्यूशन होगा इसके लिए एमबीआर के
लिए और कोई होगा और यूएफ आ के लिए ई जो
ईएफ आई बूट लोडर है ये होता है तो इनके
लिए थोड़ा सा नाम अलग हो सकते हैं लेकिन
काम सबके सेम रहते हैं तो उसके बाद जो
स्टेप फाइव आता है स्टेप फाइव में आता है
आपका विंडोज बूट मैनेजर हम बात करते हैं
विंडोज बूट मैनेजर की तो बायोस रीड द
एमबीआर बायोस ने एमबीआर को रीड किया व्हिच
रीड्स द पार्टीशन टेबल अभी मैं बायोस के
केस में बात कर रहा हूं ऐसे ही आप जीपीटी
के केस में बात कर सकते हो तो बायोस यूएफ
आई के केस में बात कर सकते हो बायोस रीड द
एमबीआर उसने मास्टर बूट रिकॉर्ड को रीड
किया व्हिच रीड द पार्टीशन टेबल एंड लच द
बूट सेक्टर उसके अंदर एक फाइल हो बूट
सेक्टर उसको लच कर देगा व्हिच देन स्टार्ट
बूट mgr's
[संगीत]
उसको क्या कर देता है एग्जीक्यूट कर देता
है स्टार्ट कर देता है वन बूट मैनेजर रन
देन इट एक्चुअली रीड बीसीडी डट फाइल जब
आपका बूट मैनेजर है क्योंकि जब आपने जो
एमबीआर पार्टीशन पढ़ लिया उसकी जो 51 टू
12 जो बूट सेक्टर था जब उसको देखा उसके
अंदर आपके बूट एज फाइल मिली वो क्या करता
है बूट मैनेजर जिसको हम बूट मैनेजर बोलते
हैं वो बीसीडी ड डेट फाइल होती है एक आपके
जिसके अंदर उसी के अंदर सिस्टम के अंदर
आपके विंडोज सिस्टम के अंदर बूट अ बूट
पार्टीशन के अंदर उस फाइल को क्या करता है
रीड करता है दिस बीसीडी डेट फाइल इज
एक्चुअली ए क्रिटिकल रजिस्ट्री फाइल
एक्चुअल में जो डेट फाइल है बीसीडी फाइल
है ये एक रजिस्ट्री फाइल है अब रजिस्ट्री
क्या होती है विंडोज के अंदर मैं आपको आने
वाले टाइम में बिल्कुल डिटेल में बताऊंगा
कितने टाइप की रजिस्ट्री है किस रजिस्ट्री
में क्या काम होता है बट अभी के लिए
रजिस्ट्री समझिए एक प्रकार से एक डेटाबेस
होता है जहां पर आपके जो विंडोज की सारी
जितनी भी सेटिंग या जितनी भी कॉन्फिन की
जाती है वो रजिस्ट्री के थ्रू ही की जाती
है आपके विंडोज के अंदर तो ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ
दैट इट टेल्स योर बूट मैनेजर हाउ टू बूट
योर सिस्टम और यहां पर क्या होती है इस
डेटाबेस के अंदर इंस्ट्रक्शंस होती है कि
इस बूट मैनेजर के लिए कि इस पीसी को इस
मशीन को बूट कैसे करना है ओके इस मशीन को
बूट कैसे करना है तो आपके पास पता चल गया
एमबीआर के अंदर बूट सेक्टर था बूट सेक्टर
में आपको बूट एज . बूट मैनेजर था जैसे वो
एग्जीक्यूट की उसने सबसे पहला काम किया
गया बीसीडी फाइल थी उसको रीड किया वो एक
डेटाबेस था उसके अंदर इंस्ट्रक्शन थी कि
इस मशीन को कैसे बूट करना है देन जो सिक्स
स्टेप आया आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लोडर
विनलोड डसी अभी जैसे जो बीसीडी डे फाइल थी
स्टार्ट द विंडोज लोडर उसने क्या किया इस
फाइल ने जो विंडोज विनलोड डसी है विंडोज
जो लोडर है जो जहां से एक्चुअल ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम लोड होगा उसको स्टार्ट किया उस
फाइल को ऑन द बूट पार्टीशन बूट पार्टीशन
के ऊपर जो कहां पर लोकेट होता आपका
नॉर्मली आपका विन विज सिम 32 winload.exe
अगर आप देखने की कोशिश करो तो आप देख नहीं
पाओगे क्योंकि ये हिडन होता है ओके और
नॉर्मल यूजर इसको नहीं देख सकता क्योंकि
जानबूझ के विंडोज के द्वारा इसको हाइड
किया जाता है अब इसका विजुअल क्लू क्या
होता है अगर आप देखोगे तो इस तरीके से
आपको स्क्रीन देखने को मिलती है इसका मतलब
क्या है आपकी विनलोड एक फाइल है वो क्या
कर रही है लोड हो रही है ओके और जब तक
आपकी लॉगिन स्क्रीन नहीं आएगी तब तक यह
क्या होता है आपको एक विंडोज की क आजकल
क्या है कि
आपके उसका नाम आता कोई लोगो आ जाता आपके
लैपटॉप का आपके मशीन का लेकिन पहले क्या
आता था स्टार्टिंग विंडोज इस तरीके से
लोगो आता था तो इस अगर जब मशीन बूट हो रही
होती है उस टाइम पर अगर इस तरीके का लोगो
आता है इसका मतलब क्या है कि आपका
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लोड हो रहा है हम अभी
सिक्सथ स्टेप पर हैं इसका मतलब हम कहां पर
हैं सिक्स्थ स्टेप पर हैं जब सबसे पहले
कुछ ब्लैक कलर की विंडोज पर बहुत सारी
इंस्ट्रक्शन आई थी तो वो क्या था अभी उस
केस में अ मैं आपको बात करूं तो इस केस
में आपका पोस्ट टेस्ट हो रहा है
समझ जाना कि आप स्टेप टू पर हो और इस केस
में आपका क्या है अभी स्टेप सिक्स के ऊपर
कि आपका जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है वो लोड हो
रहा है अब जब विनलोड है वो क्या करती है
कि एक विंडोज कर्नल को लोड करती है साथ के
साथ एक डीएलएल फाइल होती है हार्डवेयर
एब्स्ट्रेक्शन लेयर उसको लोड करती है और
जो बूट ड्राइवर्स हो जैसे डिस्क है
ग्राफिक्स है इनपुट ड्राइवर्स उनको लोड
करती है अब इस टाइम पे क्या होता है आपके
कर्नल्स की जो एग्जीक्यूटिव फाइल्स है वो
भी लोड हो रही है उसको भी एग्जीक्यूट किया
जा रहा है हार्डवेयर एब्स्ट्रेक्शन लेयर
की फाइल है उसको भी एग्जीक्यूट किया जा
रहा है उसकी जो डीएलएल फाइल है उसके बाद
जो बूट लोडर्स है उसके अंदर जो डिस्क है
इनपुट ड्राइवर्स है उनको क्या किया जा रहा
है अभी इनिला इज किया जा रहा है तो यहां
तक सबको क्लियर
है
बताइए यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है यहां तक सबको को क्लियर है
एवरीवन तो विनोद आपका आंसर बाद में करूंगा
ओके तो अभी हम टॉपिक पर रहते
हैं ओके निक निक बोलता है सर अवर सिस्टम
इंफॉर्मेशन वी कैन चेंज ऑन डेस्कटॉप बट वी
कैन आल्सो चेंज इनटू बायोस टू और नॉट नो
यू कैन नॉट चेंज ओके सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन को
आप चेंज नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि आपको वहां
पर एक्सेस नहीं होता उसका सीक्वेंस अलग
होता व अटैक ही अलग होता है उसके लिए आपको
बहुत हाई लेवल का अटैकर बनना पड़ेगा इज इट
पॉसिबल बट अभी के लिए पॉसिबल नहीं है
पॉसिबल लेकिन उसके लिए आपके पास बहुत आप
मास्टर के मास्टर होने चाहिए समझ में आया
क्योंकि आपको मैं बताऊंगा कि विंडोज में
किस फाइल को कौन टच कर सकता है समझ में
आया कि विंडोज वेरी मतलब इंटरेस्टिंग
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम मैं सब बताऊंगा आपको किस
फाइल को कौन टच कर सकता कौन टच नहीं कर
सकता किसको किस लेवल के प्रिज उस तो मुझे
अभी के लिए सवाल का आंसर दीजिए सबको यहां
तक क्लियर स्टेप सिक्स तक सबको क्लियर है
तो
बताइए आगे चले अभी बचा हुआ है थोड़ा सा
ओनली बूट सीक्वेंस करवाऊं बूट प्रोसेस आज
में बताइए बताइए बताइए ओनली दे टू एंड
थ्री स्टूडेंट्स आर आंसरिंग माय
क्वेश्चन ओके
नेक्स्ट स्टेप सेवन आता आपका मैंने आपको
बताया था जो विनलोड है वह क्या करती है
आपकी जो अभी ये स्क्रीन कंटिन्यू चलती
रहेगी क्योंकि सेम टाइम आपका जो कर्नल भी
इनिला कर्नल की जो फाइल होती है एनटीओ के
आ एए वो भी इनिला इज होती है जिसमें क्या
होता है एसेंशियल ड्राइवर्स रिक्वायर टू
स्टार्ट द विंडोज कनल आर लोडेड कि वल जो
विंडोज का कनल है उसको लोड करने के लिए
जिन ड्राइवर की जरूरत है ड्राइवर की जरूरत
है उनको क्या किया जाता है लोड किया जाता
है एंड कर्नल स्टार्ट टू रन और कर्नल क्या
करता है रन करना स्टार्ट हो जाता है एंड
लोडिंग इन टू मेमोरी द सिस्टम रजिस्ट्री
हा उसके बाद क्या करता है जो कर्नल है
जैसे ही अ कर्नल रन करेगा के अंदर जो
रजिस्ट्री है हाइव है सिस्टम एक सिस्टम
रजिस्ट्री हाइव होती है हाइव क्या होती है
टर्मिनोलॉजी है इसको मैं बताऊंगा कि अभी
के लिए इतना ही याद कीजिए आपको एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा आने वाली क्लास में तो लोडिंग इन
टू मेमोरी द सिस्टम रजिस्ट्री हाइव जो
सिस्टम रजिस्ट्री हाइव उसको मेमोरी के
अंदर लोड कर दिया जाता है एंड द एडिशनल
ड्राइवर्स दैट आर मार्क्ड एज बूट स्टार्ट
उनको भी क्या कर दिया जाता है आपका लोड कर
दिया जाता है और जब कर्नल अपना काम कर
लेता है जैसे कर्नल ने अपने काम खत्म कर
लिया ड्राइवर एसेंशियल ड्राइवर्स को लोड
कर लिया उसके बाद रजिस्ट्री हाइव को लोड
कर लिया उसके बाद जितने भी ड्राइवर्स बू
स्टार्ट के अंदर उसके प्रोसेस का पार्ट है
सबको लोड कर लिया देन उसके बाद कर्नल क्या
करता है कर्नल पासेस कंट्रोल टू द सेशन
मैनेजर प्रोसेस एक एसएमएस smss.exe फाइल
होती है इसको कंट्रोल पास कर देता है जो
क्या करती है आपकी सेशन को मैनेज करने का
काम करती है व्हिच इनिला इज द सिस्टम
सेशंस लोडस एंड स्टार्ट द डिवाइस एंड
ड्राइवर जो क्या करता है एक सेशन
एस्टेब्लिश करता है सिस्टम्स का और
सर्विसेस का जो सिस्टम सर्विसेस रन करती
है वो इसी सेशन के अंदर रन करती हैं और
जितने भी डिवाइस है ड्राइवर्स उनको
स्टार्ट कर देती है विजुअल क्लू सेम रहता
है मतलब कर्नल ने अपना काम किया कर्नल के
बाद जो नेक्स्ट जो कंट्रोल पास हुआ किसके
पास याद रखना आपको एमए डसी के पास कंट्रोल
चला गया अभी यह क्या करती है कि जो सेशन
मैनेजर क्या करता है द सेशन मैनेजर सब
सिस्टम इज ए क्रिटिकल विंडोज प्रो प्रस
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर सेटिंग अप द एनवायरमेंट
फॉर यूजर मोड प्रोसेस यह पहली प्रोसेस
होती है आपके कर्नल उस हार्डवेयर के बाद
जो यूजर्स मोड के अंदर आती है क्योंकि एक
तो आपका यूजर स्पेस होता है एक आपका
हार्डवेयर स्पेस होता है हार्डवेयर स्पेस
के बाद जो सबसे पहली प्रोसेस रन करती है
यूजर स्पेस के अंदर वो होती है आपका सेशन
मैनेजर ओके सो इसलिए इट इज आल्सो ए
क्रिटिकल विंडोज प्रोसेस रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
सेटिंग अप द एनवायरमेंट ये करता है एक
अपना एनवायरमेंट सेट अप करता है जो जिन
प्रोसेसेस की जिन ड्राइवर्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट रन करने के लिए उनको
इनिशियली में स्टार्ट करता है इट इज द
फर्स्ट यूजर मोड प्रोसेस दैट रंस आफ्टर द
विंडोज कनल हैज इनिश इइ ज्ड द सेशन मैनेजर
प्ले ए की रोल इन हैंडलिंग सिस्टम वाइड
टास्क बिफोर द यूजर लॉगिन यूजर के लॉगिन
करने से पहले जितने भी सिस्टम वाइड टास्क
जो अ रन होने चाहिए या जो सिस्टम सर्विसेस
रन होनी चाहिए वो सारी स्टार्ट कर देता है
ओके कौन सा सेशन मैनेजर क्योंकि सेशन
मैनेजर रंस इन सेशन जीरो रंस इन सेशन जीरो
सेशन जीरो क्या होता है मैं आपको बताऊंगा
ये सेशन जीरो के अंदर रन करता है वहि इज द
सिस्टम सेशन वेयर सर्विसेस एंड सिस्टम
प्रोसेसर अब सेशन जीरो एक ऐसा स्पेस होता
है जहां पर आपके जो सिस्टम सर्विसेस है या
सिस्टम प्रोसेसस क्या करती है रन करती हैं
उसके अंदर क्या करता है ये रन करता है अब
की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी क्या है इसकी इनिला इज
सिस्टम एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल लोड द
रजिस्ट्री हाइव क्रिएट अन मैनेज सिस्टम
सेशंस स्टार्ट क्रिटिकल प्रोसेसेस सिस्टम
प्रोसेस जैसे कि विन
लगन csrss.exe एसस . जो ऐसी बहुत सारी जो
सिस्टम्स की जो क्रिटिकल प्रोसेस है जो
आपकी स्टार्ट होनी ही चाहिए आपके सिस्टम
को रन करने से पहले ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
सक्सेसफुली बूट अप करने के लिए तो उनको भी
ये स्टार्ट करती है कौन सा सेशन मैनेजर
एंड कंफिट वर्चुअल मेमोरी ओके तो ये सारी
इसकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है एक तो एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल सेट अप करता है ये भी रजिस्ट्री
को हाइव को लोड करता है उसके बाद सेशन को
मैनेज करता है देन जो क्रिटिकल प्रोसेस है
जो नेक्स्ट है विनल जहां पर हम लॉग इन
करते हैं एल सास के अंदर हमारे पासवर्ड्स
होते हैं इन सारी प्रोसेस को क्या करता है
ये स्टार्ट करता है अभी हम बात करते हैं
नेक्स्ट हमारा सेशन जीरो क्या होता है
सेशन जीरो इज द फर्स्ट सेशन
क्रिएटेड्रॉअर्नेविगेटर
सिस्टम प्रोसेसेस एंड द सर्विस जो सिस्टम
की जो प्रोसेसेस है जो सर्विसेस है उनके
लिए रिजर्व रहता है जो सिस्टम मैनेजर इज द
फर्स्ट यूजर मोड प्रोसेस एग्जीक्यूटेड बाय
द विंडोज कर्नल एंड रंस इन द सेशन जीरो ये
आपको क्लियर है इट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
क्रिएटिंग एडिशनल सेशंस फॉर यूजर लॉगिन
सेशन वन आ जितने मल्टीपल आप यूजर्स यूज
लॉग इन करते हो आप 1 2 3 4 जैसे डोमेन के
अंदर होते हैं तो उसके लिए उतने ज्यादा ही
आपके सेशंस क्रिएट होते हैं सेशन जीरो में
कोई भी लॉगिन एंटर नहीं कर सकता अगर कोई
भी नया लोग यूजर लॉगिन करता है खास करके
मैं डोमस की बात करता हूं तो क्योंकि वैसे
तो हम अपने जो लैपटॉप यूज उसमें तो एक ही
यूजर यूज करते हैं हम अरवाज मल्टीपल
यूजर्स के लिए भी उसको कन्फर करते तो उसके
लिए हर एक के लिए अलग-अलग सेशन मैनेज किया
जाता है प्रियर टू विंडोज विस्टा सर्विसेस
एंड यूजर एप्लीकेशंस रन इन द सेम सेशन अभी
जो विंडोज विस्ता था उससे पहले जो
सर्विसेस थी और जो यूजर एप्लीकेशन थी सेम
सेशन में रन करते थे उनका सेशन अलग नहीं
होता था जिससे क्या होता था जो प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन अटैक था वो आसान हो जाता था
किसी भी अटैकर के लिए विंडोज विस्टा के
बाद जो सेशन जीरो आइसोलेशन वाज
इंट्रोड्यूस्ड सेशन जीरो को इंट्रोड्यूस
किया गया जिसको सेपरेट रखा गया सिस्टम
सर्विसेस और यूजर एप्लीकेशन से सिक्योरिटी
रीजन से अभी जो सिस्टम की सर्विसेस हैं वो
सारी सेशन जीरो के अंदर रन करती हैं और
यूजर जो एप्लीकेशंस है वो अलग सेशन के
अंदर नके इसलिए क्या है ये एनवायरमेंट
आइसोलेटेड करके रखा गया ठीक है सैड बॉक्स
करके रखा जिससे क्या एक दूसरे से व क्या
नहीं करती इंटरफेयर नहीं कर सकती जो जो
यूजर एप्लीकेशन है वह सिस्टम सर्विसेस के
साथ इंटरफेयर नहीं कर सकती तो सब मुझे
बताइए जो स्टेप एट था सेशन मैनेजर क्या
होता है उसकी क्या रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज है व
किस सेशन के अंदर रन करता है और सेशन जीरो
क्या आता है सबको समझ में आ गया या नहीं
आया सबको समझ में आया या नहीं
आया बूट पार्टीशन में होता सबसे
ये निकनिक बूट पार्टीशन के
अंदर तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है नेक्स्ट स्टेप पर चले उसके जो लास्ट
स्टेप उस पर चलते हैं हम इसका किसी कोई
डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास वोटिंग सिक्स
रिलेटेड अभी के
लिए किसी का कोई भी डाउट
ओके
नाउ जो फाइनल स्टेप हमारा बूट प्रोसेस का
वह क्या है इस तरीके से आपको कई बार लॉगिन
स्क्रीन देखने को मिलती है जहां पर आपका
क्या है विलन फाइल लोड हो जाती है ओके
जैसे आप इस पर स्पेस टेप करते हो क्लिक
करते हो तो आपको यहां पर क्या आते है यूजर
नेम और पासवर्ड के लिए मांगता है आपका
पासवर्ड के लिए या पिन के लिए एक स्क्रीन
आती है तो यह आपका फाइनल प्रोसेस होती है
आफ्टर द सेशन मैनेजर हैज कंप्लीटेड इट्स
इनिला इजेशन द विंडोज लोगन प्रोसेस बिगन
विंडोज की जो लोगन प्रोसेस है वो स्टार्ट
हो जाती है दिस इवोल्स टू की सिस्टम क
इसके अंदर दो की सिस्टम्स मेनली होते हैं
एक तो विन एक्टी ये एक साथ स्टार्ट
होती है विन लगन t एक्सटी क्या करता है
आपको लॉग इन स्क्रीन प्रोवाइड करता है
जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया इस तरीके से
आपको यह वॉलपेपर दिखता है और आप स्पेस
क्लिक करते हो यहां पर यूजर नेम एंड
पासवर्ड के लिए आपके पास स्क्रीन आर तो ये
क्या ये इसके लिए कौन रिस्पांसिबल होता है
आपका winlogon.exe उसके बाद एसस . ये होता
है लोकल सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी सब सिस्टम
सर्विस इसके बारे में आपको बता दूंगा क्या
होता है प्रीक लेशन जब एडवांस लेवल पे
करते हैं ना तो इसको हम डिस्कस कर सकते
हैं एल सास डंप करते हैं ना जब हम तो ये
वही होता है तो लोकल सिक्योरिटी ऑ यहां पर
आपके क्रेडेंशियल होते हैं आपके पासवर्ड्स
होते हैं एक प्रकार से डेटाबेस होता है जब
आप लॉग इन करते हो करेक्ट यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड तो वो इस डेटाबेस से जो एलस है
प्रोसेस है इससे वह मैच करता है और उसके
बाद क्या होता है कि ओके या इफ पासवर्ड
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड आर करेक्ट देन आप
सक्सेसफुली क्या कर लेते हो लॉगिन कर लेते
हो देन क्या होता है विलगन स्टार्टस यूजर
लगन स्क्रीन अपीयर्स और सर्विस कंट्रोल
मैनेजर होता है स्टार्ट सर्विसेस व
सर्विसेस को स्टार्ट कर देता है लेटेड टू
दैट पर्टिकुलर यूजर जिस यूजर से मैं लॉगिन
कर रहा हूं उससे रिलेटेड जो भी उसकी ग्रुप
पॉलिसीज होंगी जो भी उसकी स्क्रिप्ट होंगी
जो भी ऑटोरन स्क्रिप्ट होंगी या जो भी
उसके रिलेटेड जो भी सर्विसेस हैं जो भी
उसके प्रोग्राम्स होंगे वो सारे उस यूजर
रिलेटेड क्या करेंगे उसके एनवायरमेंट के
साथ ये स्टार्ट कर देता है आपका सर्विस
कंट्रोल मैनेजर व्हेन द यूजर लॉग्स इन जब
जैसे आपका यूजर लॉग इन करता है विंडोज
क्रिएट ए सेशन फॉर दैट यूजर उस यूजर के
लिए एक सेशन क्रिएट कर देती है जिसको हम
बोल सकते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल सेशन वन देन
जैसे ही आप सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन कर लिए देन
उसके बाद एक और होती है एक्सप्लोर . अभी
हमें इंटरनेट एक्सप्लोरर की बात नहीं कर
रहा एक प्रोसेस स्टार्ट होती है जैसे आप
लॉगइन कर लेते हो
एक्सप्लोर एकसी दिस
सिस्टम क्रिएट द डेस्कटॉप विंडोज मैनेजर
जब जब भी आप क्या करते हो जैसे आप लॉगइन
करते हो उसके बाद आपको डेस्कटॉप
एनवायरमेंट मिलता है जैसे आपको टास्क
मैनेजर है दे लॉट ऑफ एप्लीकेशंस है सबको
रन कर सकते हो एक जीआई मिलता है जो एक
डेस्कटॉप एनवायरमेंट उसके लिए कौन सी
प्रोसेस रिस्पांसिबल होती है
एक्सप्लोर एक्स स्टार्ट द सिस्टम द
डेस्कटॉप विंडोज मैनेजर प्रोसेस वि इलाज द
डेस्कटॉप एंड डिस्प्ले जो आपको इतना साफ
सुत ना क्लीन एंड नीट एंड क्लीन डेस्कटॉप
को देखने को मिलता है वो किसकी वजह से
देखने को मिलता है आपका एक्सलो डसी की वजह
से तो सबको समझ में आया या नहीं
आया बताइए यह था आपका कंप्लीट बूट प्रोसेस
ऑफ विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम स्टेप वन से
लेकर फाइनल स्टेप तक कितने स्टेप परफॉम
सबसे पहले सब कुछ मैंने आपको डिटेल में
बताया है कि ए एससीयू ने क्या किया मदर
बोर्ड में क्या काम किया सीपीयू में कैसे
इंस्ट्रक्शन उठाई उसके बाद पोस्ट चेक हुआ
पोस्ट के बाद आपके बाद नेक्स्ट
हमारा आपको मैंने बताया था पोस्ट के बाद
अगर इफ यू रिमेंबर ये रहा बूट डिवाइस को
लॉक किया उसके बाद बूट लोडर एग्जीक्यूट
किया बूट लोडर ने क्या किया बूट मैनेजर था
बूट मैनेजर ने रजिस्ट्री फाइल को उठाया
रजिस्ट्री फाइल में इंस्ट्रक्शन लिखी हुई
थी फिर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को लोड किया गया
देन उसके बाद कर्नल को लोड किया गया देन
उसके बाद सेशन मैनेजर सेशन मैनेजर के बाद
आपका क्या आता है विज लोगन उसके बाद
एक्सप्लोरर ड तो द जादा सब सिंपल स्टेप्स
बट इसके लिए बहुत बड़ी कहानी है अगर मैं
बात करूं जो सेशन मैनेजर या विन लोगन या
एसेस या एक्लो इनके ऊपर बात करूं तो मैं
दो सेशन भी डिलीवर कर सकता हूं इतने डीप
नॉलेज इनके ऊपर जो अवेलेबल है जो आप पढ़
सकते हो बट एज ए बिगिनर्स इट्स एनफ फॉर यू
ओके गाइस तो आई थिंक जो विंडोज का बूटिंग
प्रोसेस थी शायद आज के बाद आप लोगों को
उसके अंदर डाउट नहीं होगा सबको क्लियर
है हां यह मैं प में डलवा
दूंगा तो किसी को डाउट है मुझसे पूछ सकते
तो मैं आपके डाउट सेशन पर आ जाता हूं अभी
तो शायद अभी के लिए आपका सेशन इतना ही था
और रिलेटेड टू आप चेक कर सकते हो अभी मेरे
को यह बताइए किसी को डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ
सकते हो सबको विंडोज की बूट प्रोसेस समझ
में आई अगर फिर भी अगर विंडोज की बूट
प्रोसेस आपको समझ में नहीं आई तो आप एक
काम कर सकते हो कि एक बार आप फिर से देखिए
कल सेशन को रिवाइज कीजिए नोट्स आपके
एप्लीकेशंस में मिल जाएंगे और आप क्या कर
सकते हो फिर अपने
सेशन के मजे उठा सकते हो तो व्ट इज
विनोद विनोद आपका क्वेश्चन मैं समझ नहीं
पा रहा हूं कि आप मुझसे क्वेश्चन पूछ के
सर मैं सोच रहा हूं कि आफ्टर कंप्यूटर
हार्डवेयर के बाद ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पढ़ूं
लाइक विंडोज के एक प्लेलिस्ट सोची थी करने
के का लेकिन समझ नहीं रया कि क्या वो मैं
कितनी वीडियोस आएंगे आई डोंट नो कि आप
एक्चुअल क्वेश्चंस क्या है
आपका आप सेम क्वेश्चन कट कॉपी पेस्ट करो
मुझे समझाया पूछ क्या रहे हो मैं समझा तो
रहा हूं बेसिक प्लेलिस्ट विंडोज की एक
लेवल डिलीवर तो कर रहा हूं और क्या चाहिए
देखि निक निक अगर आपका सवाल मैं फिर से
समझ नहीं पा रहा कि आप बोल रहे आवर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन वी कैन चेंज न
डेस्कटॉप ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन
डेस्कटॉप पर कैसे चेंज कर सकते हो आवर
सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन बट आल्सो वी कैन चेंज
इनटू बायस टू आवर और
नॉट किस मुझे एक एग्जांपल के थ्रू पूछिए
कि आप मेरे से क्या पूछना चाह रहे हो कि
शायद मैं आपका फिर क्वेश्चन अच्छे
से आंसर कर सकता हूं
कहां पर रन करने के लिए बोल रहे हो
जगतगुरु
जी ओके तो यह बूट पार्टीशन के अंदर होती
है यार बूट पार्टीशन को आप कितना ओपन
करोगे छेड़छाड़ नहीं करनी चाहिए बूट
पार्टीशन के साथ
मान सिंह शर्मा मैं आपको बार-बार मैं आपको
नहीं बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स को मैंने बोला
है कि आपको याद नहीं रखनी
कमांड्स
आपको समझना है कि मैं अभी क्या कर रहा
हूं मैं अभी क्या कर रहा हूं और मुझे किस
टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करनी है और
मैं अभी क्या करने वाला हूं उससे रिलेटेड
आप एक चीटशीट बना के रखिए अपने नोटपैड के
अंदर या इवन आपके वन वन नोट के अंदर या
जहां पर भी आप कंफर्टेबल हो वो चीटशीट आप
साथ के साथ लिख के रखिए बस उसके सामने लिख
लीजिए कि पर्टिकुलर जो कमांड मैंने यूज की
थी जब मैंने इस कमांड को सीखा था इस कमांड
का परपज क्या था इसके साथ मैंने जिस ऑप्शन
को यूज किया था उसका परपज क्या था और जैसे
आपका उससे रिलेटेड जो आपको परपस फिलफिल
फुलफिल करना है तो आप सिंपली उस कमांड को
कट कॉपी पेस्ट मॉडिफाई करके पेस्ट कर
लीजिए इतना ही तो करना
है लॉगिन पेज के पहले
क्या जगत गुरु जी
देखिए अभी मैं अगर लेटेस्ट विंडो 11 की
बात करता हूं या उससे रिलेटेड हार्डवेयर
की बात करता हूं इट वेरी परफेक्ट काफी
उसको परफेक्टली डिजाइन किया गया है और
परफेक्टली उसके हार्डवेयर पार्ट को डिजाइन
टीपीएम हो गया आपका या सिक्योर बूटिंग हो
गया तो मतलब आपके लिए इतने चैलेंज बढ़ गए
जिस बात की जिस चीज की आप बात कर जगत गुरी
थोड़ा सा हार्ड है ठीक है क्योंकि उसके
लिए रूट किट्स या बहुत सारी चीजें
इंप्लांट करनी पड़ती है ओके तो पॉसिबल है
बट फेलियर चांसेस ज्यादा है
तो पासवर्ड एट वर्ड पासवर्ड है आपका अपर
लोअर केस न्यूमेरिकल क्रैक नहीं हो रहा है
सर अगर एक बात बताइए कि हो कंफर्म आपको
पता है कि 8 बिट पासवर्ड है
वो कंफर्म
हां अभी बेस्ट तो विंडोज में कोई बेस्ट
नहीं
है विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को जैसे मैं
आपको समझाऊ तो आपको समझ में आए कि विंडोज
काम कैसे करता है विंडोज एनवायरमेंट काम
कैसे करता
है अगर आप एक्सप्लोइट लिखने में आप मालवे
लिखने में आप य आर वेरी गुड एक्सप्लोर
डेवलपमेंट तो आप किसी भी एंटीवायरस को
बायपास कर लेकिन वो उसके लिए आपको लेवल की
नॉलेज और उस लेवल की आपके पास स्किल होनी
चाहिए काली में वाईफाई एडेप्टर काम नहीं
कर रहा किशन कुमार क्या इशू है कि चच टाइप
काली में वाईफाई
एडेप्टर देखिए अगर क्या आपने बाहर से
वाईफाई एप्टर यूज कर रहे हो
या आपने डेवल बूट किया हुआ है सवाल यह
है देखो सीआईडीआर का टॉपिक बहुत बड़ा है
मान सिंह शर्मा कि उसको टाइम लगेगा और अभी
मेरे पास उससे रिलेटेड मैंने कोई स्लाइड
बनाई हुई नहीं है और मेरे पास अभी लिटरली
अभी ऐसे कोई पेन वाला सीन नहीं है कि मैं
लिख के समझा सकता हूं तो क्योंकि सीआईडीआर
को आपको मैं मोटा मोटा बताऊंगा तो वो तो
आपको इंटरनेट
ट्राई किया होगा समझ में नहीं आया होगा तो
मे भी मैं आपके लिए अ क्या हेल्प कर सकता
आप मेरे को टैग कीजिए मैं आपसे एक अच्छा
आर्टिकल दे सकता हूं उसपे आ वीडियो दे
सकता हूं समझा सकता हूं लेकिन अभी इतना
टाइम नहीं है कि मैं भी समझा दूं क्योंकि
छोटी सी एक दो लाइन में समझाऊ तो आपको सच
में समझ में नहीं आएगा क्योंकि यह क्या ता
कि आईपी रेंज को मैनेज करने के लिए काम
आता नेटवर्क नेटवर्क के अंदर मल्टीपल आईपी
को रेंज को मैनेज करने के लिए काम आता है
बेसिकली और हां मेरे को करो
कृष्ण ठाकुर आप एक काम कीजिए मेरे को
बताइए एक्चुअल में आपका क्या
है तो विंडोज 11 डिफेंडर बायपास कर 10
डिटे डिटेक्ट कर लिया हाउ इ
पॉसिबल शायद कुछ ना कुछ आपने विंडोज
डिफेंडर में कमी की होगी सही से उसको
कन्फर कीजिए विंडो डिफेंडर को
हो सकता है कि वो ओनली पासवर्ड के साथ-साथ
और कुछ भी यूज कर रहा हो यार पासवर्ड तो
आप क्रैक करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो लेकिन
उसके लिए कोई सेशन मैनेज कर रहा तो हार्ड
है मुश्किल है तो उसके लिए आपको फिर सेशन
टेकओवर करना होगा या कुकीज फाइंड आउट करनी
होगी या पूरा सेशन टोकन चाहिए होगा आपको
उसके लिए तो वह अलग अप्रोच मेन आपको यूज
करनी
होगी तो शायद आप लोगों को कोई और सवाल
नहीं है तो मैं सेशन को एंड करूं
बताइए सेशन को एंड करें फिर
बताइए तो थैंक यू रोकी अगर आपको डिटेल में
अच्छा लगा है तो एक काम कर सकते हो फिर
फॉलो बाकी लोगों को भी बो
बोलिए फॉलो करें सब्सक्राइब करें और शेयर
कीजिए और हमारे
डिलीवर करेंगे आपको आने वाले सेशंस में और
भी मजा आएगा ओके खास कर की विंडो से
रिलेटेड
ओके विंडो से रिलेटेड आपको उसमें और भी
मजा आएगा तो आप कृष्ण ठाकुर एक काम कीजिए
आप मेरे को इस इस लिंक दिन पे क्या कर
लीजिए जो मैं आपको भेजा है इस परे मेरे को
रिक्वेस्ट भेजिए मैं एक्सेप्ट कर लूंगा आप
वहां पर मैसेज कीजिए आपकी हेल्प डेफिनेटली
की जाएगी मेरे द्वारा
तो आज को सेशन को एंड करते हैं
[संगीत]
और तो बाय बाय टेक केयर सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन गुड नाइट